ولذلك تلاحظ، كن رجلًا
الرجل من يفعل كذا
هي عناصر القوة، النجدة
الفزعة، القيام بالحماية
هذه العناصر تحتاج لقوة بدنية، قوة ذكرية
فإذا ترقّى وأخذ بعض هذه الأخلاقيات
والتزم بها، سنمسيه رجلًا
إذا اعتبرنا أن الأخلاق سلم
سيكون هذا الرجل قد حقّق السلم
بدرجات محدودة منها
فإذا تقدّمنا خطوة وقلنا أنه أصبح ذو مروءة
هنا نتحدث عن المرء والمرأة
ولاحظ أن المرأة هي رتبة فوق الرجولة
فالرجل إذا صعد من مرحلة الرجولة أصبح مرأة؟
أصبح مرءًا
مرءًا
أنت تحاول أن تحفر لي فخًّا لا أعرف ما هو
الحاسّة عندي تقول أن فيه مشكلة ما
أهلًا هذا فنجان من ثمانية
وأنا عبد الرحمن أبو مالح
الهَوية أو الهُوية
اليوم باتت
موضوعًا هامًّا، شائكًا، حاضرًا في كل يوم
الهوية الفردانية والثقافية والوطنية
أو الدينية أو العرقية
والهوية الإنسانية معقّدة ومشربكة
الحديث فيها يبدأ ولا ينتهي
وتقدر تتناوله من جهات عديدة مهمة
هذه الحلقة
حبيت أن تكون من الجانب الأخلاقي
الجانب الفلسفي
ما هي الهوية؟ ما هو الإنسان؟
ما هي مراتب الأخلاق عند الشخص؟
يقول ضيفي أن ترتيب الأخلاق عند الإنسان
أول مراحله الرجولة، فالمروءة، فالفتوّة
وهنا تجي أسئلة كثير
ما هي الرجولة أصلًا؟
هل هي مرحلة عمرية أم درجة أخلاقية؟
وإذا كانت أخلاقية، فهل تكون المرأة رجلة؟
يقول ضيفي أن المرأة من المروءة
واللي هي تبدأ من درجة كمال الرجولة
الحلقة فلسفية من العيار الرفيع
مع ضيفي العزيز، أبو عبد الرحمن
سليمان الناصر
الباحث في فلسفة الأخلاق
قبل أن نبدأ
دائمًا
الحلقة في فنجان
تكون مليانة معلومات
أكثر مما في الحلقة ذاتها
تلقى مصادر ومعلومات إضافية
سواءًً ذكرها الضيف
أو وجدناها في البحث
ما قبل الحلقة، وهي مهمة ومثرية
والتفاصيل كثيرة
ما تلقى لها مكان في الحلقة
وتروح هباءً منثورا
فحبيت أجمعها في مكان للمهتمين
ففي وصف الحلقة
رابط الاشتراك في نشرة فنجان البريدية
تصل بريدك لحظة نشر الحلقة الصوتية
صباح كل أحد
فاشترك من خلال الرابط
أما الآن
لنبدأ
تدري الحلقة جات من وين أصلًا؟
لا والله ما أدري
الشيخ
كذا عنده فضول
في مسألة الرجولة
وأحس أن دائمًا يجي السؤال عند الناس
سواءً الرجال وللا النساء
ليش تقول في الأشياء الجيدة تقول عنها رجال؟
يعني ليش تقول خلّك رجّال؟
حتى لو على سياق المرأة
تجي تقول امرأة عن ألف رجّال
أو ممكن تقول رجّالة؟
لا، هذا اللي ولا أبوك يا عقاب
أنا ببعد عنه
بس أنت تشوف أن دائمًا الرجل..
فهل الرجل معنى؟ هل هي شي جديد مستحدث؟
وللا هو من قديم، ودائمًا يضرب به المثل؟
تبي تترك هذا مدخل يعني؟
أنا اقترحت بديل
إضافي يقول تسمية الأشياء
لا، اللي هو الهوية البشرية
الهوية البشرية
أحسه بيكون موضوع أشمل
لأن أنا اقتراحي
أن احنا نتناول..
بالبدايات يعني
الدخول مباشرة على الهوية
ممكن عن معنى الرجولة
ما بيكون مؤسّس
إذا دخلنا بالبداية بتعريف الهوية البشرية
ونتناول فكرة الهوية ما هي؟
وليش هالقلق العالمي ذا على موضوع الهوية؟
كل أنواع الهوية
طيب أجل وش الهوية إذن؟
احنا بدينا نصوّر؟
إيه
أنا جالس أحاول أننا نبدأ
لدينا مصطلحان، مصطلح الهُويّة بالضم
لأنه ما يشيع هو الهَويّة
وهذا طبعًا خطأ
وكذلك أيضًا المصطلح
الذي أطلقه بعض المفكرين العرب الآن
الذي هو الهووي
هذا يشيع، لما يقول هووي. فكلا النسبتين خطأ
فتح الهاء خطأ
وأيضًا النسبة خطأ
يعني نسبة الواو والياء هذه
وهناك الماهية
الهوية في البدايات القديمة
هي ما يكون الشيء
يعني «أ» هو «أ»
اللي هو الوجود، بالضبط، الهوية هي الوجود
فأنت موجود يعني هويتك هو
هذه منسوبة إلى هذا، أن أنت موجود
في حين أن الماهية
هي صفات هذا الشيء الموجود
يعني ما هو؟
الماهية هي جواب ما هو؟
فالماهية هي ما يكون الشيء هو نفسه فيه
ويحقّق ذاته
ولكن الاستعمال الموجود الآن عند العرب
هو العكس
أصبحنا نطلق الهوية على الماهية
يعني احنا لما نقول الهوية الثقافية
لا نقصد الوجود الثقافي
إنما نقصد هذه الصفات الثقافية
وعندما نقول الهوية الاجتماعية
أو الهوية السياسية
أو كائنًا ما كانت الهوية
وحتى نقول مثلًا أن المؤسسة لها هوية معينة
ثمانية لها هوية معينة
لا نقصد وجود ثمانية، هي موجودة
ولكن نقصد صفاتها
لكن هذا الانزياح أصبح معمولًا به
ومتواضع عليه
ولا يوجد فيه إشكال
أصبح الناس كلهم
يتحدثون عن الصفات بأنها الهوية
لما نتحدث مثلًا عن الهوية البشرية
فلا نقصد الوجود البشري
وإنما نقصد صفات هذا البشر
وطبعًا الخزان الذي تتواجد فيه تعريفاتنا
والإشارة إلى قيمنا
ومعارفنا وفهومنا، هو اللغة
التي يتواصل الناس بها
فاللسان العربي له ثلاثة مصطلحات
أو لنقل تجليات، لهذا الكائن
الذي نتحدث عنه
الذي أشكل على أخيه الإنسان
كما يقول التوحيدي
له ثلاث مسميّات: مسمى الإنسان
ومسمى البشري أو البشر، ومسمى الآدمي
في البداية لا بد أن نحدد مسارنا
هناك مساران في تناول هذه المساحة
المسار المعهود عند البشر
هو الذي فيه تقاليد راسخة
وتأسّست عليها القيم الأخلاقية
وتعامل البشر بعضهم مع بعض
هو المسار الأخلاقي
يعني النظر إلى هذه العلاقات
من منظور قيمي وأخلاقي
لماذا؟
لأن الأخلاق أساسها هي هذه الأفعال البشرية
بعضهم مع بعض
الأخلاق هي الفعل
وبالأساس فعل الإنسان مع الإنسان
فبالتالي
المجال الذي يتناول
هذه الصور أو هذه المصطلحات الثلاثة
وما يتفرع عليها طبعًا من تعاملات
ينبغي أن يكون المسار الأخلاقي
هناك مسار جديد مستحدث
يحتاج إلى طرح مستقل ونقاش مستقل
وهو الذي بدأ مع الثورة الفرنسية تقريبًا
وهو المسار الحقوقي، الذي بدأ بسؤال الحقوق
ثم تطور إلى هذا
ما يُسمى بالانفجار الهوياتي
الموجود في العالم، الذي يتناول
مسائل الجندر
وهذه الإشكالات التي تبدأ ولا تنتهي
ويبدو أننا في بداية الطريق
لا نزال في بداية الطريق؟
لأن الفكرة المركزية فيه
هي تغوّل مفهوم المساواة
وتعرف أن الشعار الذي أُطلق
في الثورة الفرنسية
هو
المساواة
المساواة والإخاء والإنسانية
وهناك ملاحظة أطلقها مؤرّخ مشهور
المؤرخ اليهودي، هراري نوح
أطلق ملاحظة طريفة
وحقيقة هذا الرجل شيطان في ملاحظاته
هذه الملاحظة أطلقها في كتاب
اسمه الإنسان الإله
يقول إن البشرية نادرًا ما تبتكر قيم
نادرًا جدًّا
وهذا حقيقي
وهذا يتضمن تسليم مفيد ونافع
وهي أن البشرية كأنها جاءت إليها هذه القيم
في لحظة مبكرة واستمرت معها
فيقول إن اللحظة التي وُلدت فيها
في العصر الحديث قيم جديدة
هي لحظة الثورة الفرنسية.
وُلدت فيها هذه القيم
قيم المساواة، وقيم الإخاء
الحرية والإخاء والمساواة
هذه القيم الثلاث
طبعًا ممكن تقول أن الحرية أصلًا موجودة
لكن نتحدث نحن بالفعل عن معنًى جديد
الذي هو الحرية الفردانية المطلقة
وبالنسبة للمساواة أيضًا المساواة المطلقة
وبالنسبة للإخاء
فله أيضًا دلالته الخاصة الحديثة
بعدين يتحدث هو لاحقًا بأن الآن مثلًا
مع الذكاء الاصطناعي جاءتنا قيم جديدة
وهي قيمة حرية البيانات
ويفرق طبعًا بين حرية البيانات
وحرية الإنسان
لأن حرية الإنسان منسوبة إلى الإنسان
في حين أن حرية البيانات
منسوبة إلى البيانات نفسها، قصة ثانية طويلة
نرجع إلى الفكرة التي أشار إليها
وهي أن البشرية أطلقت مع الثورة الفرنسية
أو لنقل أوروبا أطلقت مع الثورة الفرنسية
مفهوم المساواة المطلقة
الآن كل هذه التداعيات باتجاه هذا التضخم
لمفهوم المساواة
وأنت تعرف هذه الحركة
اللي يسمونها حركة اليقظة
هو في النهاية فكرتها المركزية
أنه لا توجد فروق
أن هناك نوع من..
اليقظة، يعني أن نستيقظ عن هذه الخديعة
التي تفشّت عند البشرية وهي وجود فروق
طبعًا الفروق بين الرجل والمرأة
فروق بين الأسود والأبيض
فروق بين الشمال والجنوب
فروق متعددة
والآن وصلنا إلى مرحلة
الفرق بين الحيوان والإنسان
أن حتى فكرة الفرق بين الحيوان والإنسان...
وهذه لن تنتهي
يعني هذه فكرة ربما...
سيكون ليس هناك فرق بين الروبوت والإنسان
أمامنا طريق...
وهذا طريق فيه مشكل في الحقيقة
-من جانب الحقوقية؟
-نعم، ولا نريد أن نسلكه
أنا أعتقد
أن الطريق الذي يحل المشكلات
ولا يجترح مشكلات جديدة
هو الطريق الأخلاقي
لأنه هو الألصق بالهوية الإنسانية
ما هو الإنسان؟
باللسان العربي فيه عدّة تعريفات
لكن التعريف المشهور يقولون من النسيان
ولكن التعريف الآخر هو من الأنس
يعني أن الإنسان هو الذي..
بطبيعته، بوجوده، يأنس بإنسان آخر
ويأنس به إنسان آخر
ولما نقول التعريف
ما فائدة التعريف؟
يعني أنه لا يحقّق هذه الإنسانية
حتى يحقق معناها
يعني كلما حقّقت هذا الأنس
كلما حصّلت من الأنس مع البشر
وكلّما حصّل البشر فيك أنسًا
كلما حققت معنى الإنسانية
وكأن نقص معنى الإنسانية مشكل بالنسبة لك
فأنت إذا لم تشعر أن الآخرين يأنسون بك
أو أنك أصبحت أنانيًّا
فقط تأنس بهم
ولا تهتم بأنسهم بك
فهذا فيه مشكلة
وتعرف طبعًا
الأنس ما هو؟
والأنس مركّب من عنصرين:
عنصر المحبة وعنصر القرب
فالإنسان قد يحب إنسانًا، ولكنه بعيد
فهو لا يأنس به
بالعكس، يشعر بالوحشة
عندما نقول وحشتك يعني شعرت...
كأنه  إذا فقد شخصًا أصبح وحشًا
في حين أنه إذا التقى بهذا الذي يحبه
أصبح إنسانًا
والثاني هو القرب
أحيانًا يكون شخص قريبًا منك
ولكنك لا تشعر بالأنس به
لعلك تشعر بالأنس مع القريبين معك
صحيح
من أجل أن تتحقّق الإنسانية
فالأنس يتحقق بهذين المعنيين
وطبعًا لما نتحدث عن مفهوم الأنس
ومفهوم القرب
فكلها لها..
كل مفهوم أخلاقي
يتركب من عناصر أخلاقية أخرى
يعني في التحليل
سنذهب إلى عناصر أولية
البشرية
أيضًا هناك تعريف أخلاقي لها
وهو أن البشرية مأخوذة من البشر ومن البشرة
كيف تكون بشرة؟
بمعنى أن الإنسان
هو الكائن الذي له هذه البشرة
التي لا يغطيها ريش
ولا يغطيها شعر، وإنما بشرة
تشف وتكشف عن بشره الداخلي
فإذا استبشر وشعر بالشر تبيّن
إذا جاءك بشير وبشّرك بشيء، تبين لك
صحيح أنها أيضًا تشف عن الحزن والصدمة وكذا
ولكنهم اختاروا هذا المسمى
نوعًا من التفاؤل
لأن الأصل في الإنسان أنه كائن مشاعري
كائن له أخلاق، وله بعد باطني
يعتمل في الداخل، فيظهر حتى على وجهه
إذا أتينا للآدمية
فالتعريف المشهور عادةً في الكتب
أن الآدمية مأخوذة من أديم الأرض
لأن آدم خُلق من التراب
ولكن هذا المعنى لا يعطي بعدًا مميّزًا
على الأقل إذا كنا قرّرنا
أن نأخذ المسار الأخلاقي
فلنبحث عن بعد أخلاقي في هذا المعنى
وأشار له بعض الباحثين
وإن كانوا من المتأخرين
ولكنه معنى، حقيقة، جدير بالاعتبار
وهو أن الآدمية...
يعني كما جاء في الحديث: أن يؤدم بينهما
يعني أن يُؤلف، من الألفة ومن الائتلاف
ومنه الإيدام
الإيدام هو خليط
من مجموعة من العناصر في الطعام
بحيث تشكّل وجبة لذيذة، مفيدة، نافعة
فكذلك الآدمي
هو يشكّل مع الاخرين هذه العلاقة
الأنس، وعلاقة التعاون، وعلاقة المحبة
فبهذا المعنى
سنلاحظ أننا حاصرنا هذا الكائن
بمجموعة من التعريفات الأخلاقية
طبعًا تعرف أن التعريف الأشهر
في التاريخ الفكري
ليس هو التعريف الأخلاقي
وإنما هو التعريف
على الأقل من الناحية النظرية
التعريف العقلاني
يعني الإنسان هو الكائن الذكي
أو الكائن العقلاني
ولما نقول تعريف الإنسان بأنه كان عقلاني
هذا أن الصفة التي يجب أن تحكم
كل تصرفاته هي العقل والذكاء
في حين أن العقل والذكاء هي تقنية
أداة تقنية
أداة..
ليس فيها تقويم
في حين أن الأخلاق
ما هي المقولة المركزية
في الأخلاق، الحاكمة؟
هي مقولة الخير والشر
كما أننا نقول في الاقتصاد
هناك مقولتي الربح والخسارة
وفي الجماليات هناك مقولة القبح والجمال
أو الحُسن
في المجالات الإنسانية
هناك مقولتان حاكمتان
في الأخلاق هناك مقولة الخير والشر
ما هو الخير والشر الذي في الذكاء؟
الذكاء قد يكون شريرًا وقد يكون خيّرًا
وإذا نظرنا أيّهما يعلو على الآخر؟
فسنجد أن الذكاء يندرج
يعني يمكن أن يوصف
ما دام أنه يوصف بالخير والشر
معناه أنه فرع، وأن الأعلى، المقولة الحاكمة
هي مقولة الخير والشر
فإذن، الحقيقة أن المقولة الأرفع والأعلى
هي مقولة الخير الشر
ولذلك المقولة المشهورة
أن العقل يدلّك على الأنفع
الأنفع هو نافع، ولكن ليس بالضرورة
أن يكون خيرًا أو شرًّا
قد يكون ضارًّا هذا النافع
يعني النفع بمعنى الزيادة
في حين أن المروءة تدلك على الأرفع
يعني هذا على الأنفع، وهذا على الأرفع
هذا يعطيك نفع، ولكن هذا يعطيك سمو
ويحقق هذا البعد المتسامي والأخلاقي
وقيل الأجمل، والأجمل أيضًا مقولة تسامٍ
مقولة الجمال بالمعنى القديم
وليس فقط بالمعنى الحسي الحديث
فهذه المعاني هي التي تحدّد مسارنا نحن كبشر
ويجب أن تحكم هذا المسار
وطبعًا خلال المسيرة البشرية
حدثت تغيّرات وانحرافات
مثلما قلت لك، هذا التعريف الذي حدث
أصبح مشكل كبير في التعريف
وامتد حتى في الحضارة الحديثة
وعلى فكرة، أنا أعتقد أن هذا الاهتمام
بالتقنية والروبوتات، والذكاء الصناعي
هو امتداد
لهذا المعنى
تعرف أن المقولة الحاكمة
في الحداثة التقنية، مقولتان:
مقولة كل شيء ممكن
والمقولة الثانية أن كل ما أمكن صنعه
وجب صنعه
فليس هنالك تفكير هل هو ضار أو نافع؟
إلى أين يفضي؟
هذا ليس مهمًّا
التقنية تقول افعل، انتج
والحقيقة هذا الذي بات يقوله..
تعرف المقولات التي ظهرت والمراجعات
حول موضوع الذكاء الصناعي
هل استعجل البشر؟ هل راجعوا؟
لأن الأمور تنفلت
ما دام الموضوع تقنية، تنفلت
وحرية البيانات التي يقولها هذا الرجل
هراري نوح
قصده أن البيانات استقلّت
لأنه يقول أننا نحن في صدد..
كما قلت لك من قبل
أنها في أول الطريق
يقول نحن في صدد فصل مفهومين
مفهوم الوعي، ومفهوم الذكاء
احنا عادةً في المنظور الإنساني نربط بينهما
ولذلك الناس الذين يتفاءلون
في موضوع...
يقولون لا
لابد أن يكون هناك وعي، ولا يمكن للآلة
أن تكون واعية
المقولات المطروحة..
أنا لا أدري هل سيتحقق لاحقًا أو لا؟
لا أعرف عن جذور هذا
من الناحية التقنية والفكرية
ولكن الحديث الدائر بينهم
أن ما يتجه إليه البشر
هو فصل الوعي عن الذكاء
وطبعًا إذا انفصل الذكاء
سيتحكم الذكاء
لأنه الأقوى
سيتحكم في الوعي الإنساني
بس معليش، عرّف لي الوعي والذكاء
الوعي هو هذا الإدراك الداخلي
في الإنسان بالمحيط
يعني الحيوان...
ما الفرق بين الإنسان والحيوان؟
الحيوان عنده إدراك بذاته
لا نقول ولا نستخدم كلمة الوعي
ولكن يقولون مثلًا
أنه لما يرى المرآة، فلا يميز أن هذه صورته
وإنما يعتقد أنه..
شفت الطفل لما يشعر
أنه مركز، والمحيط هو خارجه؟
وكأن العالم، آخر
وليس أنه جزء من هذا العالم
في حين أن هذا الكائن الإنساني
لديه إحساس داخلي
وعي داخلي
أنه هو هذا الكائن، وأن هناك آخر
هناك غير
ويشعر بغيره، ويفهم ويعي أنه واعٍ
في حين أن الحيوان
كما يقول العلماء المعاصرون
أنه لا يملك هذه الخاصية
ما عنده وعي؟
نعم ليس لديه وعي
بس هل يمكن أن يكون الحيوان ذكي؟
ممتاز، هذا سؤال ممتاز في الحقيقة
يعني يساعد في فهم الموضوع
لمّا عرفوا الإنسان بأنه كائن ذكي
كأنهم قصدوا أن الحيوان ليس ذكيًّا
في حين أنت تلاحظ في الأفلام الوثائقية
فهو ليس فقط ذكاءً عاديًّا
ذكاء، ترتيب
وتنظيم، وتخطيط
ما يُسمى بالذكاء الاستراتيجي أو التخطيطي
هو لا ريب أن من تعمّق في هذه المقولات
سيصل إلى أن التعريف الحقيقي للإنسان
هو هذه القيمة الخلقية
وهذا بالمناسبة
أصبحت
تقوم عليها المراجعات الأخلاقية الحديثة
في الفلسفة الأخلاقية
مثلًا في فيلسوفة اسمها كريستين كورسغارد
فلسفتها في فلسفة الهوية البشرية
وهذه المعاني
تقريبًا أصبحت فكرتها الرئيسية
حول فكرة الهوية البشرية
والهوية العملية
وكيف أن الإنسان هويته العمل
يعني يسعى لتحقيق الأعمال
التي تحقّق وجوده
وبالتالي يجب أن تكون هذه الأعمال...
يعني أصبح هذا محل لمناقشات حديثة
بل حتى أنهم ربما
من أيام جان جاك روسو
بل المفاجأة أنك ستجد أن فيلسوفًا
اشتهر بأنه غير أخلاقي
بأن هذا هو تعريفه للإنسان، وهو نيتشة
فنيتشة يعرّف الإنسان ليس بأنه كائن ذكي
بالعكس، نيتشة ربما
من خصوم المنطق والذكاء
وإنما يعرّف الإنسان بأنه الكائن المقوّم
الذي لديه خاصية التقويم
يقوّم الأشياء
إذا أتينا هنا، سنقول أن نيتشة
تقويماته مختلفة
التقويمات الغريزية
القوة، والحيوية. مختلفة
ولكن نحن لا نذهب إليه إلى آخر الطريق
ولكن نتفق معه في هذه الفكرة
أن الإنسان كائن يقوّم
أما الحيوان لا يقوّم
لا يطرح التقويمات
ولذلك من الطرائف يُقال في تاريخ الفلسفة
هذا النقاش في تعريف الإنسان
أن سقراط ربما
أو أفلاطون
عرّف الإنسان
بأنه..
احتار، ما هو التعريف المناسب؟
فعرّفه بأنه كائن له قدمان
يمشي على قدمين
فله تلميذ ربما، أو منافس، أو خصم
اسمه ديوجين، مشهور
يعني يقوم على الاعتراض
تعرف فكرة الاعتراض..
أنا أعترض، أنا موجود
الإنسان يحقق شيئًا من وجوده
أو الاعتراف به من خلال..
الاعتراض
وإذا كان الاعتراض قائمًا على آداب أخلاقية
فلا بأس به، فشيء جيد، بالعكس
المقصود
أن هذا الرجل كيف كان اعتراضه؟
لم يتكلم
وإنما جاء ومعه دجاجة منتوفة الريش
حيّة، وقذف بها في الحلقة
وقال هذا إنسان بالنسبة لك
فأراد أن يُبطل بشيء يشاهده بعينه
نعود ونقول أن التعريف
الذي سارت عليه حضارتنا
وتتشبّع به لغتنا
وقيمنا وأعمارنا
والحقيقة أنه التعريف البشري العام
وإن كان لا يُقرّ به نظريًّا
لا يُقرّ به نظريًّا
لما تقول حضارتنا
تقصد العربية وللا الإسلامية؟
الاثنتين
الاثنتين؟
ما في اختلاف بينهم؟
قد تكون فيه فروق تقتضيها....
ولكن على قلب هذه الثقافة
الإسلامية العربية
هي هذه المعاني والقيم التي توجد في..
النص الثقافي والديني الإسلامي
وأيضًا من خلال تشبّع اللغة العربية بها
هي أن الإنسان كائن أخلاقي
كائن فاعل، يفعل
ولما نقول فاعل...
يعني مثلًا من التعريفات المبكرة لهذا
هو تعريف جان جاك روسو
جان جاك روسو يقول إن الإنسان هو هذا الكائن
الذي يختار
يعني يترقّى
فالترقي هو فعل، والفعل هو الأخلاق
ما هي الأخلاق؟ الأخلاق هي أفعال
الأخلاق هي أفعال
ربما اللّبس الذي يأتي عند الناس
هو التمييز بين الفعل الإنساني
وبين المعاني القارّة في الباطن
التي نسميها القيم أو المعاني أو الفضائل
الاسم القديم عندنا هو الفضائل
الآن الاسم الحديث، الحداثي، هو القيمة
أو نقول المعاني، وأحيانًا القدماء
يطلقون عليها الأخلاق
يعني مثلًا قيمة الصدق في داخلك، هي قيمة
لكن فعلك للصدق أو الكذب، هذا فعل
الاصطلاح السائد الآن في الفلسفة الأخلاقية
والبحث الأخلاقي، والفكر الأخلاقي
هو أن هذه المعاني نسميها القيم
وأن الفعل نسميه تخلّق أو أخلاق
في حين في القديم، كانوا يسمونها فضائل
والحقيقة اسم «فضائل» ألصق بالمعاني القديمة
ولكن فيه عيب، وهو أن الفضيلة
كأنها فضلة زائدة، في حين أن القيمة
هي معنًى حديث، ولكنه يقوّم
يعني يعطي الأشياء قيمتها
أنت تقوّم، تحكم على الشخص
بأنك تقول كاذب أو صادق
أنه وفيّ أو غدّار
أنه عنده مروءة أو لئيم
أو تقول إنسان
أو شخص، كأنك تنزع عنه إنسانيته
أو تقول هذا آدمي، نوع من التقويم له
وأيضًا التقويم بمعنى
إقامة المعوّج
لأنك عندما تصفه...
وهو في الحقيقة واحد
أنك تصفه، بمعنى أنك تقوّمه
فالشاهد أن..
فالخلاصة أن الهوية البشرية في الحقيقة
هي هذه الهوية
ذات المعنى الأخلاقي، التقويمي..
في البداية كنت أقول أن روسو يقول
أن الإنسان هو الكائن الذي يرتقي
قصده أن يقارن بين ارتقاء الإنسان والحيوان
فيقول أن الحيوان لا يتغير
والإنسان هو الذي يرتقي
حتى أذكر أنه مثّل بالقطة
فقال القطة مثل جدها العشرة آلاف، لا تختلف
في حين أن الإنسان، لا، يختلف
لماذا؟ لأنه يختار
ويكسر
فالقط إذا أتيته له ربما
بأكلات مختلفة، لا يقبلها
في حين أن الإنسان، نعم يكسر
وهذا الكسر قد يكون إلى الأعلى
وقد يكون إلى الأسفل، يعني هي لها وجهين
وهذا هو الاختبار له، أن الإنسان حر
يعني أن لديه هذا الاختيار
بس مو ممكن برضو أن موجود عند الحيوان
في الانتقاء والتطور؟
ربما هذا يحتاج إلى عالم مختص
لا أستطيع أن أفتي
ولكن قصدي أن الفكرة السائدة
التي نراها بأجمعنا
هو هذا، أن هناك أكل ثابت
مثلًا حتى في الحياة الحديثة
تذهب إلى سوبر ماركت
هناك أكلة خاصة للقط
أكلة خاصة لـ ...
كأنه اعتاد على هذا
لنقل أن التحرر الذي يحدث للحيوان
بسبب الإنسان
يعوّده ويدربه، ربما
نعود إلى هذا المثلث
الذي هو الإنسان والآدمي والبشري
وقلنا أنها كلها تدل على معانٍ
أخلاقية في هذا المجتمع
بين هذا الكائن الذي نسميه الإنسان
سيتفرع عن مفهوم الإنسان مراتب
مثلًا، المعهود عندنا، والموجود في اللغة
لدينا مفهوم الرجولة
تفرّع عن الإنسان
ثم لدينا مفهوم المروءة
الرجولة، اشتُقّ منه مفهوم الرجل
وفي بعض اللغات مفهوم الرجلة
ولكنه لا يُستعمل
وللا موجود في اللسان العربي
الرجلة؟
الرجلة، نعم
ولكنه أُُهمل وما عاد يُستخدم
وأحيانًا يُستخدم استخدام الذم
لأن المرأة تتشبه مثلًا أو كذا
يُقال عنها رجلة، بهذا المعنى
ولكن أصبح الرجل علامة على الذكر
لدينا أنثى وذكر
هذا تقسيم الجندري
الذي ينبني عليه الاتجاه الحقوقي
لكن بالاتجاه الذي لدينا
لدينا نحن الرجل
ثم سنجد مفهوم المروءة
الذي نأخذ منه
المرء والمرأة
ثم سنجد أن مفهوم الفتوة
مفهومًا أخلاقيًّا سنأخذ منه الفتى والفتاة
وهذه كلها معانٍ لها بعد أخلاقي
ربما مفهوم الرجل يختلط
بين المعنى الأخلاقي
والمعنى البيولوجي، الذكري
يعني أن هناك قوة
ولذلك قد يكون، والله أعلم
أن اللسان عربي اقتصر بإطلاقه على الرجل
بسبب هذا البعد الذكوري
يعني القوة، الصلابة
الشدة، الذهاب إلى الحرب
هذه المعاني التي جرت العادة
بأن يختص بها الرجال دائمًا وأبدًا
ولكن أُُعطيت هذا المعنى، الرجولي
بمعنى الترقي في هذه الإنسانية
لأننا نحن نقول أن الإنسانية هي..
لنقل أن الإنسان هو الكائن ذو الأخلاق
بغض النظر عن التزامه بها
هو الكائن ذو الأخلاق
يعني لديه الأخلاق بالقوة، وليس بالفعل
فإذا ترقّى
وأخذ بعض هذه الأخلاقيات والتزم بها
سنسميه رجلًا
في سياق مخصوص، سنسميه رجلًا
أيًّا يكن جنسه؟
لا، أنا أتحدث الآن أنا عن الذكر
فنقول أن الذكر إذا تمسّك ببعض الأخلاقيات
وهذا الشرط معناه أنه إذا تخلى عنها
فقد تخلّى عن هذا الوصف
ولذلك كن رجلًا، الرجل من يفعل كذا
هي عناصر القوة، النجدة، الفزعة
القيام بالحماية
هذه العناصر تحتاج لقوة بدنية، قوة ذكرية
فمن من يحقّقها يرتقي بسلم الإنسانية درجات
فنقول هذا الرجل حقق مجموعة من...
إذا اعتبرنا أن الأخلاق سلم
سيكون هذا الرجل قد حقّق السلم
بدرجات محدودة منه
فإذا تقدمنا خطوة وقلنا أنه أصبح ذو مروءة
هنا نتحدث عن المرء والمرأة
ولاحظ أن المرأة هي رتبة فوق الرجولة
بهذا المعنى
إذا نظرنا بهذا المنظور
الرتبة الأخلاقية
التي يُنسب إليها المرء والمرأة
هي فوق الرتبة الرجولية
لأنها تتضمن ما هو أكمل منها
فما هي المروءة؟
المروءة هي كمال هذه الرتبة التي قبلها
كمال الرجولة
هكذا يعرّفونها
وأوّل من عرّفها تعريفًا مبكّرًا
هو الفراهيدي
في كتابه العين، عندما عرّف المروءة
قال هي كمال الرجولية
فدلّ على أن هذه القيم التي تُطلق عادةً
على من يرتقي تلك الدرجات
هناك درجات أعلى منها، توصف بأنها مروءة
وطبعًا إذا ذهبت إلى الكتب الأخلاقية
وهي من أمتع الكتب
التي يمكن أن تقضي فيها وقتًا
من أمتع الكتب
خصوصًا الكتب الأخلاقية
التي تعرّف مفهوم الرجولة
مفهوم المروءة، مفهوم الفتوة
وحتى مفهوم الكرم والرجاء
هذه المفاهيم الأخلاقية التي تشكّلنا
إذا ذهبت إلى تعريفاتها
ورأيت كيف يعبّر عنها القدماء
سواءً شعراء أو حكماء
أو الأخلاقيون المتصوفة أو الفقهاء
كل واحد ينظر لها من زاوية
هذا يذكر تعريفًا
وهذا يذكر تعريفًا
وأنت تهيم في هذه الحديقة الغنّاء
فلا تجد إلا روائح زكية
ومعاني جميلة، وأنوار
ثم طبعًا..
ربما إذا أتيت إلى الواقع وجدت شيئًا آخر
ولكن على كل حال
هذا هو الذي يسمو إليه الإنسان
الإنسان كائن سامٍ، يسمو
فهو يتطلّع إلى هذه المعاني
فالمسميات الثلاثة
الإنسان والرجولة والمروءة
تقريبًا، تتحدث عن الكائن ذو الأخلاق
ويتفاوت في تمسكه بالأخلاق
بين إنسانية أو رجولة أو مروءة
لنقل أن المروءة هي كمال الأخلاق الإنسانية
كمال الأخلاق الإنسانية، المروءة
وتندرج فيها أخلاقيات كثيرة جدًّا
هذه من الأخلاق الأساسية
أو لنقل من أمهات الأخلاق
لأنه يندرج في داخلها أخلاق كثيرة
فإذا عدّدوا، وتحدثوا عن المروءة
قالوا هو الذي يكف شرّه غيره
والذي يفعل كذا..
يذكرون أشياء كثيرة
ولكن الميزة الرئيسة، أو الفارقة المائزة
بين هذه القيم الثلاثة
الإنسانية والرجولة والمروءة
وبين القيمة الثالثة، قيمة الفتوة
في الغالب، أن هذه الثلاثة
تقتصر في داخل الإنسان
يعني كأنها عناصر تزكّي الإنسان
أنه يزكّي نفسه
بغض النظر عن علاقتها بالآخر
لاحظت؟
فكأنها تخلّق تجاه الذات
فيقولون مثلًا المروءة هو أن الإنسان
لا يفعل ما يشين، وإنما يفعل ما يحسن
وهي كلمة جامعة، شاملة
أشياء كثيرة تشين بالإنسان
سواءً على مستوى العلاقة مع الآخرين
سواءً على مستوى اللبس
سواءً على مستوى الأكل
سواءً المستوى الكلام
أشياء كثيرة تشين بالإنسان
وهذا الشين الذي يلحق بالإنسان
ليس فقط أمام الآخرين، بل أمام نفسه
حتى إذا خلا بنفسه، فهناك مروءة
ولذلك
ربما بعض المصنفات
التي توسّعت في تعريف المروءة
تحدثت عن مروءة الإنسان مع نفسه
ومروءة الإنسان مع غيره
ومروءة الإنسان مع ربه
فلاحظ أنه حتى بينه وبين نفسه، في الخلوة
هناك مروءة
فيقولون أنه لا يفعل ما يشين به
إذا فعله مع الآخرين
إلا إذا احتاج
هناك أشياء تخصّ الإنسان
لابد أن يفعلها في خلوته
ولكن بشكلٍ عام
من الأمثلة الطريفة يقولون الأكل بشره
الإنسان إذا خلا بنفسه، أكل بطريقة...
أو مثلًا تحدّث بطريقة، أو كذا
أو فعل أشياء، لا يفعلها أمامنا
فيقولون هذا يزري بمروءته أمام عينه
أمام عينه
وربما يظن بعض الناس أن هذا فيه تنطّع
أوفيه..
وهو ليس كذلك بل هو تزكية
ما هي التزكية؟
هو هذا التطهير، هذه التنقية
لذلك القرآن مثلًا
ذكر مجموعة مواصفات
يربطها بلفظ
مثلًا في رجال كذا، فيقول مثلًا
في المسجد الذي أُُسّس على التقوى
قال
فِیهِ رِجَالࣱ یُحِبُّونَ أَن یَتَطَهَّرُوا
والطهارة هنا معنًى عام
ليست فقط الطهارة الحسية
وإنما فكرة الطهارة العامة
النقاء الداخلي، فكرة النزاهة
أن يكون الإنسان نزيهًا
وفكرة النزاهة فكرة عظيمة جدًّا
تقوم عليها الآن مبادئ
تُشغل المجال الفلسفي العالمي
مثلًا فكرة المسؤولية، فكرة مركزية
وكثير من الحراك والتقدم والتجديد
الذي يحدث في الأنظمة
على مستوى القضاء والعدليّة
والأنظمة على مستوى الدولة
وعلى مستوى المجال العام
هي متفرّعة عن فكرة المسؤولية
يعني واحد من عناصرها الأساسية
مبدأ النزاهة
لدرجة أنهم مثلًا يقولون الآن
أن بعض سياسات الإصلاح العدلي
تقوم على تهيئة المجال العام
من خلال تخليق المجال العام
يعني إذا كان عندنا اهتمام بجودة الحياة
وهذا شيء مهم جدًّا
أيضًا المفروض أن عندنا اهتمام بتخليق..
أنا أقصد الحين الحياة العامة
فكذلك ينبغي أن يكون عندنا اهتمام بتخليق
الحياة العامة
ببث قيم النزاهة والمروءة
طبعًا بالتأكيد
بالتأكيد
أنه يرفع مستوى علاقة البشر بعضهم مع بعض
ولكن أيضًا يساعد في تحقيق الأهداف المرسومة
لمثلًا وزارات العدل وكذا وكذا
يعني يُعتبر أحد العناصر في إصلاح القضاء
هو تخليق المجال العام
مع أنه قد لا يبدو
في بادئ الرأي
أن هناك علاقة
لكن الحقيقة هناك علاقة
فالمقصود أن المروءة هي هذا
هو هذا التخلّق الذي يخص الإنسان في ذاته
هناك درجة أعلى التي نتحدث عنها، وهي الفتوة
الفتوة
ربما سأشير، إذا بقي وقت
عن ما هو البعد اللغوي في الفتوة
التي ارتبطت بهذا المعنى الأخلاقي؟
لكن عن معنى أخلاقي أهم
الفتوة هي كمال كل تلك الأخلاقيات
ولكنها متعديّة إلى الآخرين
عندما نتحدث عن أن الإنسان يتعدّى
في فعله الأخلاقي
في نجدته، وفي عطائه
إلى الآخرين، لدرجة أنهم يقولون مثلًا
في بعض التعبيرات التي وردت عن القدماء
مثل جعفر بن محمد
من آل البيت
وبعض القدماء
أن الأخلاق مثلًا
مثلًا
هذا جعفر بن محمد، رضي الله عنه
سأله شخص مالـ ..
ربما، مالفتوة؟
ربما
نسيت والله
ربما، مالفتوة؟
فقال له بأنها أنك تشكر إذا أُُعطيت
وتصبر إذا مُنعت
قال هذا يفعله كل أحد
وإنما الأخلاق هو أنك تشكر إذا مُنعت
وتصل إذا قُطعت
أو شيء من هذا القبيل
بمعنى أنك لا تكافئ الآخرين بما يفعلون لك
وإنما أن تكون أرفع منهم
وهذا هو لما نقول فعل الأرفع
ولا تقابل الآخرين بما يفعلونه
وإنما أن تكون أكثر عطاءً
أكثر نجدةً
كلمة النجدة
النجدة
هذا المصطلح..
هذا خلق جميل جدًّا، وجمالي وعظيم
وحتى اسمه
النجدة هو الارتفاع
النجد وما أنجد هو المرتفع
لما نقول هضبة نجد
يعني مرتفعة
فالنجد هو الارتفاع
فلما تقول النجدة
وكأن هناك ارتفاع معنوي
وحتى أيضًا ارتفاع مادي
لأن الإنسان الذي يُنجد
هو من لديه قدرة
فصاحب النجدة
نقول صاحب النجدة
ولذلك تُطلق غالبًا فكرة النجدة على الشجعان
والرجل المقدام الذي يتقدم ولا يبالي
من أجل الانتصار والحماية وكذا وكذا
فالفتوة الغرض منها
هو هذا الحد الأقصى من فعل الأخلاق
تجاه الآخرين
ولكن ربما يُقال..
طبعًا نحن لما نتحدث، لا نتحدث عن تراتب
نقول إنسان، ثم ينتقل إلى رجولة
لا، لا نتحدث عن هذا
وإنما نصف
يعني على الأقل
نقول أن هذا هو الترتيب المنطقي
ولكن عمليًّا الإنسان يتقلّب
مرةً ربما يفعل فعلًا، نقول أن هذا فعل فتوة
في مرتبة عُليا
وربما ينزل أحيانًا
ويفعل فعل مروءة
وربما ينزل..
وربما أحيانًا يخرج من هذا السلم
وهكذا، يتقلّب
الإنسان الأكمل، الذي يحرص على أن يترقّى
سواءً على المستوى الفرد
أو على الجماعة
هو محاولة التعاطي دائمًا مع الدرجات الأعلى
كلما أمكن هذا
ولا يمكن دائمًا
ولكن كلما أمكن هذا
فهي مثال أعلى
نقول مثل أعلى
يعني اتجاه نتجه إليه
إذن الذي يقوّم الإنسان في الحقيقة
ليس معايير حسية أو مادية أو بيولوجية
وإنما هي هذه المعاني التي تحقّق له
المفهوم الأول، مفهوم الإنسانية
المفهوم الأول
وهو المادة الخام لنقل
أو الأرضية الأساس
ثم يترقى في تحقيقها
إلى هذا المعنى الأخير
تذكرت الحديث عن فكرة الفتوة، لماذا؟
الفتوة صحيح أنه من الناحية البيولوجية
تُطلق على الشخص
من بعد الطفولة إلى الأربعين
أظن أن كلكم، ما شاء الله، فتيان
أنا تعديت هذه المرحلة
يعني من الناحية العمرية
تُطلق على هذا العمر
ولماذا؟ لأن هذا العمر عادةً، في قوة
فيذهب الإنسان في مرحلة فتوته وشبابه
إلى الحد الأقصى
وقوته في الحد الأقصى
بعدين يبدأ ينزل
أليس كذلك؟
إلا
مثلًا في حماسه للأشياء
في علاقاته، في عاطفته، في ذكائه
في إنتاجه، في إبداعه
تلاحظ أن تلك المرحلة
هي الحد الأقصى
فكأن منتهى القوة هي هذه المرحلة، الفتوة
فكذلك نقول أن مرحلة
منتهى القوة الأخلاقية هي مرحلة الفتوة
واضحة الربط، أليس كذلك؟
هناك ربط آخر طريف أشار له
أبو حيان التوحيدي
وهو غاية في الطرافة
هو يقول أن ارتباط الفتى بالقيم
وطبعًا أنا أصيغ كلامه بطريقة حديثة
وليس بنص كلامه
وإنما على الأقل أقرأه قراءة حديثة
كما فهمته
ربما لو رجع أحدهم إلى النص، لاعترض
لكن هكذا قرأته، في المقابسات
يقول أن هذه القيم..
كأنه يقول هذه القيم
والتعبير مني
لا زمنية
لا تشيخ
يعني معاني الجود، والسخاء، والكرم
هذه معانٍ لا تشيخ، تظل هي، هي
ولاحظ ملاحظة ذلك الرجل، الشيطان
الذي ذكرته لك، هراري نوح
عندما قال أن البشر لا يبتكرون شيئًا
من حيث الجملة
لأن هذه القيم ثبتت، لا تشيخ
لا تتقادم، لأنها خارج الزمن
هي خارج الزمن
الزمن هو الذي يسبب شيخوخة الأشياء
ولذلك لاحظ مثلًا
هناك مفهوم معاصر
وهو مفهوم مركزي جدًّا جدًّا
في الحياة الحديثة
ربما تخلى البشر عن أشياء كثيرة
وعبدوا هذا المفهوم الجديد
وهو مفهوم التقدم
دائمًا البشرية عندها مفهوم التقدم
ولكن كان تقدمها المادي، مرتبط دائمًا...
كأن هناك حبال تشدها إلى ثوابت أخلاقية
فنحن دائمًا كنّا نتقدم
ولكن لدينا ما يعدّل مسارنا
بالقيم
تختلف الحضارات
نحن لدينا حزمة مهولة من القيم
لدينا في قيمنا الداخلية
هناك الاتجاه
التي هي القِبلة كما نسميها
هناك قيم الشوق والسَوق
التي تسوقنا سوقًا
والشوق أيضًا
وكلاهما واحد
وهناك قيم المروءة، قيم العدل
قيم الحق، قيم الجمال، قيم الإحسان
هذه ثابتة عند الأجيال
لكن الآن مع الحياة الحديثة
فعلينا أن نطرح هذا السؤال بشكل ضروري
ترك البشر...
ونتحدث هنا عن الحداثة
تركت الحداثة...
وإذا قلنا الحداثة..
الحداثة لم تعد هي فقط الإنسان الغربي
الإنسان الغربي ابتكرها
ولكن أصبح الإنسان في العالم كله
إنسان حديث
لأنه أصبح مستهلِكًا
هناك منتج، وهناك مستهلك
نحن أصبحنا كلنا كائنات
فرضت علينا الحداثة قيمها
وبعضنا يقاوم
يعني هناك معاناة لهذا العالم الآخر
ففكرة التقدم تقريبًا
تقطع كل حبالها بهذه الرواسخ
من أجل أن تتقدم وتبتعد
وطبعًا لاحظ أن التقدم يقتضي الشيخوخة
ولذلك هذا السعار المحموم في الركض البشري
دائمًا كل شيء عليه البشر ينتهي بسرعة
بسرعة
يذهب إلى ما بعده
ويذهب إلى ما بعده
لماذا؟ لأنه لا ينظر إلى ما يتضمنه من قيمة
فهو فرّغه من قيمته
أصبح كل ما يبحث عنه الإنسان
هو زمني، داخل الزمان
والزمان يفني
الزمان يصيبك بالشيخوخة
يتقدم بك
ينهي صلاحيتك
فيبحث عن المزيد، ويبحث عن المزيد
ويشعر الإنسان بالتهديد
بحيث أنه باستمرار يبحث
ولذلك المقولة
التي ذكرتها قبل قليل
أن الحداثة التقنية والتقدم التقني
يقوم على فكرة أن كل شيء يمكن صنعه
وأن كل ما يمكن صنعه فيجب أن نصنعه
لماذا يجب أن نصنعه؟
لأن التقدم أصبح فريضة
أصبح هو المعنى
نحن لا نحقّق معنانا حتى نتقدم
وأصبح هناك خوف من كل عائق
ومن الشخص الذي يطلب المراجعات
لأن نقد التقدم والمراجعات ليس من عندنا
ليس من مفكرينا
أكبر من ينتقد التقدم هم المفكرون الغربيون
تشارلز تايلور هو أكثر شخص ينتقد
وفضلًا عن آخرين
ولكن هذا الرجل يقول عن نفسه..
أنه يُتهم بالأصالة والرجعية وكذا وكذا
بسبب نقده لهذه المفاهيم
لأنه يُقال لكل من نقد مفهوم التقدم
أنت رجعي، تقف في طريقنا
ابتعد عن الطريق
وليس أنهم لا يعون أن هذا التقدم
له ندوب وخسائر، بل يعون تمامًا
ولكن أيضًا من الأفكار التي تغيّرت
في المسار البشري..
سابقًا، كان يُقال الوقاية خير من العلاج
بأنك لا تضع قدمك، إلا وتعرف أين وضعتها؟
وماذا يترتب عليها؟
وهذا يُعتبر حزم وحكمة، وكذا وكذا
هذا انتهى
أصبح الموضوع مقلوبًا
العلاج خير من الوقاية، فدعني أتقدم وأغامر
شوف كلمة المغامر، والمبادرة وكذا
أن غامر، والإصابات نعالجها
يعني ما عندنا مشكلة
نحن صحيح أُصبنا بإصابات
ولكننا تقدمنا، وحققنا المطلوب، وهو التقدم
لذلك تشوف مثل مفهوم التأمين
ترى هذا التضخم الذي أصبح له، هو فكرته هذه
أنك تقدم، غامر في البحار وكذا واذهب
وهناك شركات تغطيه
حتى الخطر هذا، وحتى الإصابات وُزّعت
وُزّع دمها بين قبائل الشركات
ما عاد يحملها شخص، انتشرت
وأصبحت كل هذه العناصر تدفعك دفعًا
دفعًا
إلى أن تتقدم
هذا التقدم يبعدك عن المركز
الذي هو الأخلاق
تجد الإنسان في نهاية المطاف لا يفهم
لماذا يجب عليه أن يتمسك بالأخلاق؟
وهذا الذي يفسر لماذا ظهرت
هذه الكمية المهولة
من المعرفة الأخلاقية غير المسبوقة
لاحئ، معرفة أخلاقية غير مسبوقة
لكنها كلها نظرية
لأن هناك فراغ مهول
أحدثه هذا التقدم الذي استغرق كل هذه المدة
لا أدري، لكن ربما علينا أن نطرح سؤالًا
لماذا تسارع هذا التغيّر؟
لماذا كان هناك أشياء راسخة
عند البشر لمدة طويلة
ثم أصبحت إعادة النظر فيها
ليست فقط فضيلة
بل هو الأصل
أن تتمسك بها، الناس يستغربون
هناك كتاب مشهور
ربما من أكثر الكتب التي قُرأت وتُرجمت
وهو كتاب «الإنسان يبحث عن معنى»
لفيكتور فرانك
وهذا طبعًا أستاذ في التحليل النفسي
وهو فيلسوف
من فلاسفة المعنى
وله تجربة مريرة في المعتقلات النازية
سجلها بكتابه ذاك
لكنه ذكر صفحة نفيسة جدًّا، ثمينة جدًّا
عنونها، بحسب الترجمة
بالفراغ الوجودي
ويقول فيها، باختصار، أن الإنسان الحديث
أصبح يشعر بالفراغ
والقلق
أصبح هناك قلق شديد عند الإنسان الحديث
لماذا؟
هو يحلّل
حلّل بتحليلين
التحليل الثاني، أتفق معه وسأذكره
لكن الأول أختلف معه قليلًا
وسأقوم بتعديله، اجتهادًا
الأول يقول..
طبعًا باعتبار أنه غير مؤمن، وملحد
وينطلق من فرضية تطورية وكذا
قال هذه النقطة الأولى
يقول النقطة الأولى أنه كان عند الإنسان
لما كان حيوانًا، خاصية الرضا
الحيوان يرضى عن كل شيء
الحيوان لا يتطلّع
فهذا جزء من الوعي
وأنت لاحظ الحيوان لا يتطلّع
بل يكتفي بما لديه
ومن أجل هذا فهو لا يتطور
وهو مثل جده العشرة آلاف، هو، هو
ليس لديه...
لديه رضًا مفرط
ولكن، لنقل هذا الجين
أو هذه الخاصية البيولوجية في الرضا
الإنسان تطوّر وتركها
فأصبح قلقًا
وفقدها، بتعبيره، إلى الأبد
لا يوجد علاج، انتهينا
بما أنك إنسان فأنت قلق، هكذا
ولذلك يتحدث الفلاسفة الوجوديون
مثلًا هايدقر وسارتر وأمثالهما
يتحدثون عن القلق الوجودي
القلق الوجودي يقصدون به القلق
الذي ليس له سبب
هي كينونة
كيانيتنا كبشر أننا قلقون
فهذا الرجل، فيكتور فرانك
يشرحها بهذا الشكل
ولكن أنا أقترح أننا نعدّل هذا التعريف
فنقول هو يشعر بالحقيقة، ويقاربها بطريقته
ولكن إذا أردنا أن نعدّل
سنقول صحيح، هناك فطرة داخل الإنسان
هو يسميها غريزة فُقدت
نحن نقول فطرة بهذا الرضا
والشعور بأن هناك معنى في العالم
يبعث له هذا الرضا
ولاحظ أنه جاءها بسياق مشكلة المعنى
بالنسبة له
فنحن نقول أن الإنسان الحديث..
على الأقل ما يتحدث عنه
هو أن الإنسان الحداثي
تخلى عن هذه الفطرة، مسخها
غيّرها، نسيها
بطريقة أو بأخرى
لأن الفطرة هي مفهوم سابق
مغروس في الإنسان أو مفطور عليه الإنسان
ولكنه يجب أن ينمو من خلال العمل الديني
والتعبّد لله سبحانه وتعالى
والعمل الديني
والاتصال بالشريعة
وهكذا
مجموعة عناصر مرتبطة بمفهوم الفطرة
هي تنمي المفهوم، لئلّا يخمل
إما أن ينشط أو يخمل
فهو يتحدث عن هذا الخمول بأنها غريزة تغيّرت
هذا لا يهمنا
اللي يهمنا هو العامل الآخر
فهو يقول أن البشرية
هذا التعريف الآخر؟
العامل الآخر، هما عاملان
الأول هو هذا الذي سماه هو بالتطور
فقدان الإنسان لغريزة الرضا
الثاني، وهو الأهم
وهو...
ولاحظ أن الكتاب كُتب تقريبًا
ربما في الأربعينيات أو الخمسينيات
أن المجتمعات الحديثة فقدت التقليد
التقاليد الإنسانية
ليست التقاليد بمعناها المذموم
وأحيانًا ترجمته بالتقليد
أصبح يعطي انطباعًا
والظاهر في التعبير المستخدم
هو الـ «Tradition»
يعني التقاليد العامة، الميراث البشري
لنقل الميراث البشري
أن البشرية لديها خبرة راكمتها خلال
آلاف السنين، واختبرت أشياء كثيرة
شيء منها نقلته عن الأديان
وشيء منها نقلته عن الحكمة
يعني هذه المكينة...
واختارت منها أشياء، واستمرّت عليها
وهو مفهوم واسع، يتضمّن أشياء كثيرة
ولكن هناك تقليد بشري
يشعر الإنسان فيه بالأمان
بأنني أفعل ما فعله غيري
لا نحتاج أن نعيد اختراع العجلة
في أشياء كثيرة
فيقول هو أن البشر هؤلاء
تخلوا عن هذا التقليد
والتقليد له ميزة
مثلًا حنة أرندت تحدثت في كتابها
عن نقد الشمولية
فقالت أن التقاليد توحّد المجتمع
وتعطيهم قدرة على التواصل
وتعطيهم قدرة على إمكانية الاستقلال
لديهم قدرة، لديهم قوة، لديهم معانٍ
لديهم مفاهيم. يتواصلون
فإذا تذرّروا، تفرّدوا
وتخلوا عن هذا التقليد الذي يجمعهم
أصبحوا كيانات فردانية، ذرّة، تبدأ من جديد
واكتفوا بقوتهم الخاصة
وتخلوا عن مجموع القوة
وأنت تعرف أن المجموع ليس كالفرد
كما يُقال: أحادية المجموع
ليس كمجموع الأحادية
يعني هناك قوة، قوة أخلاقية، وقوة عملية
وقوة كيانية وجودية
فيقول تخلوا عن هذا المعنى
والحقيقة البشر تخلوا عن أشياء كثيرة
في حداثة
وإذا قلنا تخلّوا عن التقاليد
فتتضمّن تخليهم عن الدين
لو قيل لنا من أين جاءت التسميات؟
تسمية الذكر، الأنثى
الرجل، المرأة
الخير، الشر
التسميات في الحقيقة هي مفهوم إلهي
هي مفهوم إلهي
وهذا نص بالنسبة لنا نحن
وهذا حتى موجود مثلًا في التوراة والإنجيل
ستجد نصوص تدل على هذا المعنى
وَعَلَّمَ آدَمَ الْأَسْمَاءَ كُلَّهَا
نص صريح وواضح
صحيح أن هذه الأية
فيها إشكال كبير عند المفسرين في التفاصيل
ولكن المعنى الكلّي واضح
أن الله سبحانه وتعالى
علّم آدم الأسماء كلها
وإذا رجعنا لابن عبّاس
يقول أنها كل الأشياء بأعيانها
وهناك من العلماء من قال أنه علّمه التسمية
يعني كيف يسمي الأشياء
وكيفية تسمية الأسماء، ليست اعتباطًا
وإنما يعطيها المعنى الذي..
قالوا مثلًا مفهوم الحلال والحرام
والخير والشر
المعاني الكلية
وحتى في قول الله سبحانه وتعالى
ٱلرَّحۡمَٰنُ
عَلَّمَ ٱلۡقُرۡءَانَ، خَلَقَ ٱلۡإِنسَٰن
عَلَّمَهُ ٱلۡبَيَانَ
يقولون: علّمه البيان
يعني بيان حقائق الأشياء
وما فيها من خير وشر
فالإنسان ليس مادة خام
ليس روبوت
تدخل فيه بيانات...
بيانات
وليس معلومات
تدخل فيه بيانات
وهناك فرق
في حين أن الإنسان، لا
أُدخلت فيه معاني، قيم قارة توجهه
فطبعًا لما نسي البشر المسمي
الذي هو الله سبحانه وتعالى
فبالتأكيد...
أي لا معنى إلى أنك ترفض المسمي
وتؤمن بالنتيجة
«الأسماء»
هو أصلًا مشكلة الناس مع المسمي هي التسميات
لو أنه لم يتدخل، ربما ما رفضوه
فالآن هناك هذا التطرف اليساري الواضح
في رفض الأديان
وأكيد يفضي إلى هذا المعنى
التطرف الواضح والقوي في رفض كل هذه النتائج
وأن علينا أن نبدأ من جديد
يعني نعم
نقول أن البشرية
قد اختبرت هذه التسميات لفترة
وكانت ناجعة ومفيدة في فترة من الفترات
لكننا لا نحتاج إلى أن نستمر
لماذا لا نجرّب؟
في فترة من الفترات كانت مفيدة
لكن الآن ليست مفيدة
ضارّة
فيها بعد عن المساواة
فيها ظلم
وهكذا
ثم لنبدأ من جديد
شفت، لاحظت كيف؟
التقليد كله
كل التقليد البشري انتهى
لنبدأ من جديد
فأنا أعتقد، والله أعلم
أن هذا الحدث الجديد
الذي هو إنكار المسمي، وإنكار الخالق
هو حدث جديد تمامًا
وبالمناسبة، لطالما قال علماء المقالات
وعلماء تاريخ الأفكار
كالشهرستاني وأمثاله
أن البشرية لم يمر عليها في تاريخها الطويل
مرحلة، أن يجتمع الناس على إنكار الخالق
الإلحاد
الإلحاد بمعناه الحديث، وليس بمعناه القديم
الإلحاد الذي هو التعطيل
نفي وجود الأول
أو كما يسميه الفلاسفة بالعلة الأولى
يقول أن هذا لم يمر على البشرية
كمجموع بشري
وإنما يمر آحاد
آحاد، والله أعلم ما سببه
إما أهواء وللا أمراض
الله أعلم
ولكنهم أفراد
حتى ذكر ابن تيمية
وابن تيمية موافق للشهرستاني
على هذه المقولة
حتى أن ابن تيمية يقول
أن القرآن أصلًا لا يناقش موضوع الربوبية
وإنما يجعلها مسلمة
في حجاجه مع توحيد الألوهية
الذين يشركون، ويدعون مع الله غيره
يقول ما دامكم تقولون أن الله هو الخالق
الصانع، الفاعل، الذي رزقكم وأعطاكم
وكذا وكذا
فكيف تعبدون غيره؟
فكأنها مسلّمة في النقاش
فيقول أن القرآن يقوم على هذا
ربما نجد أن هناك إشارات في القرآن
في الآيات
ولكن الرؤية الكلية، هي صحيحة
فابن تيمية يستثني مثلًا فرعون
ويقول مع ذلك جحدوا بها واستيقنتها أنفسهم
فرغم من أنه جحد إلا أنه...
إلا أن ابن ابن تيمية يقول
أن هؤلاء الجاحدون
أو المعطلون، التعطيل الأكبر
من القدماء
بعضهم معطل ظاهرًا وباطنًا
وبعضهم معطل ظاهرًا
وهذا عجيب، أحيانًا العكس
المفروض الإنسان يعطل الباطن، ويظهر..
ولكن هذا نفاق مقلوب
فيقول أن فرعون كان يظهر التعطيل
ويبطن الإقرار
في حين يمثل بالنمرود بأنه من النوع الثاني
الذي ينكر ظاهرًا وباطنًا
وتعرف قصته مع إبراهيم
إبراهيم هو الفتى
سَمِعْنَا فَتًى يَذْكُرُهُمْ...
ولذلك يقولون
في أحد التعريفات الطريفة للفتى
وهذه نلحقها بالحاشية
أنه الذي يحطم صنمًا في حياته
يعني الفتى الذي يحطم...
هذا تعريف طريف
أن الذي حطم في حياته صنمًا
والصنم يعني باطل ما
فالذي حطمه في يوم من الأيام
لأنه نفع الآخرين
فالصنم كان مضلل للآخرين
فهو فتى
نعود مرة أخرى
ونقول أن البشرية دخلت هذا المنعطف الجديد
الذي هو الإنكار
لم تعد أفرادًا
ولاحظ أن الإحصاءات التي تتحدث عن الإيمان
في الغرب
مروّعة
تتحدث عن مجتمعات
الإلحاد فيها، يتحدث عن 50%
و 40%
ولو قلت 10% فهذا شيء جديد تمامًا
فنحن بلا شك..
إذا كانت هذه الدراسات دقيقة
أنا لا أعرف، فهي تحتاج إلى مختص
ولكنها كثيرة جدًّا
لدرجة يصعب الشك بها
فإن كانت هذه الإحصاءات
في موضوع الإيمان بالإله
وليس الإيمان بالأديان
وليس الإيمان بالشرائع
وإنما لإمام بوجود الإله
إذا كانت حقيقة
فنحن دخلنا، في البشرية، إلى منعطف جديد
غير مسبوق
ومتى بدأ؟
بدأ بالثورة الفرنسية
قبل الثورة الفرنسية لم يكن موجودًا
بعد الثورة الفرنسية تحوّل إلى ثقافة
إلى فلسفة
وإلى قيمة يُنازع عنها
ويُناقش عنها
ولها فلاسفتها المشهورون
وأصبحت هي الأصل تقريبًا
عند كثير من الفلاسفة
لم تكن الفلسفة قبل الثورة الفرنسية
في نزاع مع الدين
نعم، قد تطرح نفسها أنها بديل
ولكنها لم تقل
يومًا من الأيام أنها عدوة للدين
لا في أيام اليونان
ولا في أيام الفلاسفة العرب
ولا حتى في العصر الوسيط
إنما تحوّل هذا العداء
عندما أُنكر الإله مع الثورة الفرنسية
دخلنا لهذه المنعطفات
والتي لا زلنا ولم ننتهي
صحيح أننا تطوّرنا من العقلانية إلى الحداثة
إلى ما بعد الحداثة، إلى العصر الاستهلاكي
ولكن كلها في الاتجاه
لا زالت شظايا الانفجار الكبير
الـ «Big Bang»
الذي حدث في باريس في ذلك الحين
وإذا استمرّت البشرية بهذا المنعطف
منعطف الإنكار الكلي والجاحد للإله
فأنا لا أعرف إلى أين سنذهب؟
فإذا كنا قبل قليل نقول..
أن التقدم قطع صلته بالقيم الروحية
وأصبح كل التقدم داخل الزمان
لم يعد هناك شيء خارج الزمان
أصبح كل شيء داخل هذا العالم
لم يعد هناك شيء خارج العالم
لم يعد هناك غيب
ولا قيم باطنة، ولا روحانيات
لم يعد إلا هذا
حتى الروحانية، أُدخلت إلى داخل هذا العالم
فأصبح هناك روحانيات دهريّة
أو روحانيات داخل داخل العالم
لا يوجد شيء خارجه
فإذن لا يوجد شيء خارج العالم
فالآن وصلنا إلى مرحلة إنكار الإله
فالله أعلم، ولكن أعتقد أن هذه التطورات
قد لاتكون بشكل مباشر
يعني لا يعلن المناضلون عنها
هذه الصلة
ولكن في التحليل النهائي، أنت لا تجد
إلا أنها جزء من هذا التطور الذي حدث
خلال
لنقل، القرنين الماضيين
بقي شيء؟
باقي
الحين باقي أن عندي أسئلة
الحين في بداية الحديث
كتب تقول أن...
ناسي والله منهو
أتوقع أنه اليهودي
هراري نوح
أن الإنسان ما قد جاب قيم
لنقل أنه يقول أنه لا يضيف كثيرًا
يعني ما ينتج القيم إذن؟
يا سلام على السؤال
سؤال ممتاز
القيمة، أو نقل المعنى
الذي يقوّم الأشياء
هي تقابل الواقع
نحن لدينا الواقع، ولدينا الواجب
القيمة هي الواجب
ما يجب أن يكون
الواقع هو ما يكون، أو ما هو كائن
والقيمة هي ما يجب أن يكون
لو تأملت، حتى الذين يعبدون الواقعية
ويعبدون الواقع
ويصنّمون الواقع
هو يسعى إلى أن يغيّر واقعه
أليس كذلك؟
وحتى هو ينتقد المثالية
وينتقد الوجوبية
وينتقد الأخلاق
هو رغمًا عنه..
لأن هذه طبيعة فينا نحن البشر
لا نرضى بما نحن عليه
ونسعى إلى..
صحيح أننا قد نحرف، أو نختزل هذه الخاصية
أو هذه الميزة فينا، وهي السعي إلى الأكملية
ونجعلها فقط أكملية مادية استهلاكية
ولكنها، في الأصل، أنها أكملية شاملة
لأنها تشمل حتى..
يعني لاحظ أن الإنسان مثلًا لا يقبل الكذب
إذا أراد أن يكذب، يسوّغ أو يبرّر
وتجده ربما إذا أراد أن يقرّر بعض المفاهيم
مثل الأنانية أو البخل
فهو يحاول أن يسوّغها
بمسوّغات اقتصادية وتطوّرية، بشكل ما
لأنه يشعر بأن هناك معنى في داخله
يشده إلى أعلى
فالأخلاق، في نهاية المطاف
هي انشداد ما هو كائن، إلى ما يجب أن يكون
هي شد الواقع الموجود إلى المنشود
فهناك موجود، وهناك منشود نبحث عنه
نريد أن نرفع مستوى المنشود، لأنه منشود
هو منشود في النهاية
ونحن ننشد إليه، نحن نرفعه
أحيانًا نخفق
أحيانًا نرجع، ننزل
ما هو مصدرها؟
هو بحسب ثقافتك
إذا أنت مؤمن، وترى أن الإنسان مكرّم
وَلَقَدْ كَرَّمْنَا بَنِي آدَمَ
وخلقه الله خلقًا خاصًّا
فلا ريب أن هذه المعاني لم يأتي بها الواقع
يعني لا تستطيع..
طبعًا شوف
هناك محاولات في المسار التطوري
والبحث عن
أن هناك تطوّر أخلاقي، وتفسّر الأخلاق
تفسيرًا أخلاقيًّا، والأنانية
والجين الأناني
ولكن في الحقيقة كلها غير معقولة أبدًا
لأن الواقع لا يُنشئ إلا واقعًا
هذا مبدأ منطقي
الواقع لا يُنشئ إلا واقعًا
والواجب هو الذي يُنشئ الواجب
الذي يحدث، أن هناك فصلًا منطقيًّا
وهناك فصلًا كيانيًّا بين الواقع والواجب
ولكن هناك تداخل بينهما
بمعنى نحن نضفي الوجوب على الواقع
من أجل أن نرفعه، أن نعدّله
نضفي المنشود على الموجود، من أجل أن نرفعه
وهذا بالمناسبة معنى التقديس
يعني عندما يتحدث الناس
أن هناك تقديس، ويجعلون هذه الصفة مذمومة
أنك أنت تستغل الدين في التقديس
تقدّس
وأنه يجب أن ننزع المقدس عن المدنس
وأن هذا شيء دنيوي
القداسة ما هي؟
والمقدس لا يتجلى إلا في الدنيوي
ليس ما يقابل المقدس هو المدنس
وإنما يقابله الدنيوي
الدنيا ليست دنسًا
بمنظوري ليست دنسًا
نحن نسعى إلى أن نصبغ..
ما هو التقديس؟
والمقدس ما هو؟
من أسماء الله الحسنى، أنه القدوس
يعني التنزيه
المقدّس هو المنزّه المطهّر
نحن نقدسه، يعني ننزّهه عن النواقص
ونصبغ عليه الكمالات
وأيضًا المقدس بمعنى أننا
كأننا ننزّه أنفسنا
بانتظار هذه المعاني القدسية
التي تتنزّل على الإنسان
هذه المعاني الباطنة
فإذن القيم، مصدرها الحقيقي هو
عالم الملكوت، أو عالم الروح
هي من عالم الروح
ولذلك لا تشيخ، عندما قلت لك قبل قليل
أن هذه القيم ليست داخل الزمان
لو كانت داخل الزمان لشاخت
مثلها مثل كل المفاهيم الإنسانية
ولتقدّم بها السن، وانتهت، وماتت خلاياها
وأصابها الموت
ولكن هذا الدليل، وبشهادة هذا الرجل
أن البشرية لا تضيف كثيرًا
لأنها تكتفي بهذا الموجود
لأنها خارج عالم الزمن
هي في عالم الروح
وما دام أنها من عالم الروح
فهي من عالم الروح
بس ما تكون القيم تختلف، وتكون نسبية
من مكان إلى مكان، ومن زمان إلى زمان؟
فتلقى الكرم مثلًا عند العرب قيمة عالية
بينما هو في ثقافات مختلفة قيمة عادية
شوف، هو لما نتحدث نحن عن مفهوم القيمة
ومفهوم القيمة..
أنا قلت أنه مفهوم حديث
هو انتقل
الاصطلاح في الفكر الغربي
من الحقل الاقتصادي
القيمة في الأساس الـ «Value»
مفهوم اقتصادي
فانتقل إلى الحقل الأخلاقي
ونحن بالنسبة لنا، الانتقال جيّد
لأننا نجد مثلًا فكرة القومة هذه..
مثلًا أحسن تقويم
دينًا قِيَمًا
نجد لها أصل
وحاول بعض فلاسفتنا المعاصرين
إعطاء هذا المعنى
بأن القران استخدم هذا المعنى
وهو معنى صحيح
وحتى لو قلنا أن هذا معنًى حديث
فلا بأس بهذا، جيّد، ننقله
والقدماء يستخدمونه كفضيلة
ولكن كل الحقول فيها قيمة
أنا قلت لك أن الجماليات فيها قيمتان
قيمة القبيح، والحسن أو الجميل
وفي الاقتصاد
قيمة الربح والخسارة
وفي الأخلاقيات فيها قيمة
الخير والشر
فحتى في المجتمعات..
وصحيح لما تقول نسبية، نحن عندنا مشكلتان
في الأخلاق
مشكلة الذاتية، ومشكلة النسبية
النسبية هي اختلاف ثقافات أو أقوام
والذاتية هي اختلاف أشخاص
يعني تُنسب للذات نفسها
فنقول أن الأخلاق ذاتية أو الأخلاق نسبية
نعم، أنا أعترف أن تجليّات الأخلاق
تختلف من أمّة إلى أمّة
ولذلك مثلًا نحن نتحدث عن..
هذا موضوع لا أستطيع أن أتحدث فيه
منفصلًا عن ما أؤمن به
لا أستطيع
ومفهوم الأخلاق في الأساس
هو مفهوم ديني
فأنا أتحدث من منطلق الثقافة الراسخة
في سياقنا هنا
والتي أنا أؤمن بها وأنطلق منها
وأعتبرها رؤية للعالم
فلسفتي التي أنظر فيها للأشياء وأقوّمها
من خلا هذه الرؤية الدينية
رؤية الوحي
وهي تسليم، ولكن المسلّمات
لا يعني أننا لا نستطيع أن نثبتها
ونبرهن عليها في مكان آخر
ولكن الآن نتحدث فيها باعتبارها مسلّمة
فنحن نتحدث عن شيء نسميه الزمن الأخلاقي
يعني ما دام نقول نحن
أن الدين الإسلامي هو الدين الأخير
من الناحية التاريخية، الكل يتفق
على أن الدين الإسلامي، كدين سماوي
هو الأخير
ومن ناحية منطقية، أن يتضمن ما قبله
فإذا كانت المسيحية تتضمن اليهودية
وتزيد عليها
فكذلك الإسلام يتضمن المسيحية واليهودية
ويزيد عليهم
ويكون هذا التجلي الأخير للوحي
الظهور الأخير للوحي
وأنا أفضل كلمة «التجلي» وليس «الظهور»
وإنما التجلي الأخير للوحي
وهو التجلي الأكمل
فهذا أن هناك تجليات أخرى
للمعاني الأخلاقية
في المجتمعات الكتابية
فضلًا عن أن تكون هناك تجليات أخرى
لمجتمعات غير كتابية
نحن نتفق مع غير الكتابيين بالفطرة
ونتفق مع الكاتبيين بشيئين، بالفطرة والوحي
ولكننا نتميّز بأن وحينا
أنه الوحي الأخير، الأكمل
الأكمل
الذي جاء بالكمال
عادةً توصف شريعة موسى بأنها شريعة جلاليّة
يعني فيها قوّة
في حين أن شريعة عيسى
توصف بأنها قوة جمالية
يعني فيها الرحمة والرأفة
وشريعة محمد
عليه الصلاة والسلام
الشريعة الأخيرة
هي الشريعة التي فيها البعد الكمالي
لما أتحدث عن الفقه
نقول أن له وجهان
وجه قانوني
يعتمد الضبط والقياس والمحاسبة
وهناك وجه أخلاقي
فيه بعد المسؤولية الذاتية
ينظر فيه الإنسان إلى تقويمه الشخصي
لنفسه، ومروءته تجاه ذاته
وأيضًا التقويم الأخروي
الذي يؤمن به
فهذا التجلي في ثقافتنا
نحن نعتبر أنه الأكمل
نحن لا ننكر أن هناك قيم أخرى
سواءً في خارج المجال الاقتصادي
ولا ننكر أن هناك قيم أخلاقية ظلّت اقتصادية
مثل، مثلًا الاتجاه الأخلاقي النفعي
مثل؟
مثل الاتجاه النفعي الإنقليزي
أشهر مدرسة أخلاقية في العالم الحديث
هي المدرسة النفعية
تقابل الفلسفة الأمريّة الكانطية والألمانية
المدرسة النفعية تقول
أن الأخلاق هي ما ينفع، والنفع العام
ولكن نتحدث عن نفع مادي
صحيح أن بعض فلاسفتها
مثل ستيوارت مل
حاول أن يضيف النفع الأخلاق القيمي
ولكن الاتجاه العام
الذي تطوّر إلى البراقماتية
هو النفع المادي، الكمي
المعدود أو المحسوس
حتى على مستوى الجماليات
تغيّر المفهوم الجمالي
تعرف أن البشر...
الإنسان كائن جمالي، يشعر بالجماليّات
هذي فطرة فيه
وظلّ البشر يتحدثون عن الجمال لفترة طويلة
ولكن ما هي الجماليات الحديثة؟
اختُرع مصطلح جديد، اسمه مصطلح «الاستاطيقا»
اخترعه رجل تقريبًا في 1750م
اسمه بومقارتن، فيلسوف ألماني
ربما تكون هذه إضافته الوحيدة
لأنه توفي مريضًا، توفي وعمره 48
وإلا فهو على فراش الموت
اعتبروا هذا...
ولكن، سبحان الله
أصبح هذا المفهوم راسخ وسائد، وأصبحت تُعرّف
كلمة استاطيقا، وهذا الشاهد عندنا
أساسها اليوناني، وهي يونانية
هي الحس
وأنت تتساءل، كيف الحس جمالي؟
الحس شيء آخر
ولكنه أراد أن ينتقد الاتجاه
الجمالي
الذي كان يُعنى بالجماليات المعنوية فقط
الجماليات الشعرية واللغوية
والأخلاقية، باعتبار أن الأخلاق
أفق جمالي، وهذا صحيح
فهو كأنه رأى أن هذا الاتجاه اندفع
بالأخلاقيات المعنوية
وضعف الاتجاه الحسي
فأراد أن يعيد المعنى للاتجاه الحسي
وانتشر الاسم
صحيح أن الفلاسفة الألمان فيما بعد
ربما يكونوا اعترضوا عليه، مثلًا كانط
غيّر المفهوم إلى ملكة الحكم
وهيقل
يعني فيه قصة أخرى
ولكن أقصد ظل هذا المفهوم سائدًا
حتى الآن
مفهوم الاستاطيقا، مفهوم الحسي
فهذا واحد من التحولات التي حدثت
من أن حتى المفهوم الجمالي
تحوّل إلى مفهوم حسي
حسّي
فكيف بالمفهوم الأخلاقي
الذي تحول مع النفعية إلى مفهوم كمي؟
نحن، نظرًا لأن لدينا كتاب ثابت، لن يتغير
لم يتغير ولن يتغير
نظل مشدودين
نحن ثقافتنا نشأت حول هذا البحر
هذه البحيرة
هذا النهر المتدفق
اللغة، الاجتماع، السياسة، الفقه، القانون
كلها نشأت حول هذا الـ..
والميزة أن هذا النهر
سيظل متدفقًا، لن يتوقف، لن ينضب
في يوم من الأيام
وبالتالي سيظل حاضرًا
فصحيح أنني ذكرت مخاوف أنا
من أن البشرية تحوّلت وكذا
صحيح، وهذه مخاوف حقيقية
وسوف تلقي بظلالها علينا
ولكن نحن لدينا قدر من الحماية
وهو هذا النهر المتدفّق
نقترب منه، نبتعد، هذه مراحل
لكن في نهاية المطاف، لدينا شيء
لا يسمح لنا بالنسيان
فكون أننا ننتمي إلى هذا النهر
ستظل قيمنا محافظة على هذا البعد..
ولنقل أنه التجلي الأخير
للأخلاقيات
نعم، لما نقول أن الكرم مثلًا
الكل يتفق على أنه خير
وحتى هذا الآخر الذي يرفضه في مكان آخر
لو قلت له هل هو فضيلة؟
فلو رآه يعطي شخصًا آخر
سيمدحه
لكنه سيعيد النظر فيه من ناحية نفعية
ويقول ما قيمته؟ يعني لماذا تعطي؟
ولذلك حتى الانتقادات التي وُجّهت للكرم
هي انتقادات نفعية
لأن العلاقة يجب أن تكون...
يجب أن نتعود أن هناك اعتماد على النفس
وهذه المعاني
ولكن لا يوجد إنسان
لا يوجد إنسان، كائنًا من كان
تأتي له بمعنًى أخلاقي، جمالي
ويقول هو ليس كذلك
لا يمكن أن ينقلب الخير إلى شر، لا يمكن
وحتى مثلًا فكرة انقلاب القيم
هذا المفهوم المركزي
الذي جاء به الفيلسوف نيتشة
انقلاب القيم
فكرته هو استبدال قيم الخير إلى قيم القوة
ولكنك تسميها أنت قيم خير وقيم قوّة
يعني حتى لا تستطيع أن تغيّر التسمية
لا تستطيع أن تقول عن القوة أنها خير
لا تستطيع أن تسمي الظلم أنه خير
لا تستطيع
مع أنه قوة
نعم قد تعيد ترتيب الأولويات
فهذا شأنك، أنت إنسان حر
وهذه هي الأخلاقيات
الأخلاق هي فعل حر
فأنت تفعل ما تراه صوابًا بالنسبة لك
وما تراه أكمل بالنسبة لك
إذا فعلت بالفعل
القيم التي تتوافق مع الهوية البشرية
التي بدأنا فيها التأسيس
التي هي الآدمية والبشرية والإنسانية
وما تفرّع عنها من هذه القيم
فأنت تحافظ على إنسانيتك
أما إذا تخلّيت عنها، نقص من إنسانيتك
بقدر ما ينقص
وأنت تلاحظ كيف الناس تتحدث عن
فقر الإنسانية
عن تغوّل..
الآن لم تعد المسألة اقتصادية
نحن كنا نشكي من تغوّل القيم الرأسمالية
الآن لا، الموضوع صار أبعد
على الأقل القيم الاقتصادية
فيها حياة ما
الآن القيمة البياناتية، قيمة البيانات
الآن القيم المركزية..
هذا هراري نوح، يسميه دين البيانات
أصبح دينًا
نحن في مرحلة من المراحل
نسمي الرأسمالية دين
مع أنها في جزء منها حق
وليس مشكلة
ولكن رفع مستوى المنظور
إلى أن يكون منظور العالم
وتقويمي للأشياء
ومنظور مهيمن كما بتعبير بعض الفلاسفة
نطاق مركزي
ويهيمن على نطاقات الأخرى
القيمية والأخلاقية والعملية
هذا معناه أن أصبح دينًا
الآن ما يسميه هيراري نوح دين البيانات
أن البيانات أصبحت دينًا جديدًا
لها...
هذا كتابه الأخير، الإنسان الإله
طريف جدًّا
طبعًا هو دخل نادي الآلهة
أصبح يتعامل مع الإسان الجديد بأنه إله
وتعرف أن فكرته الرئيسية
أننا نحن، نحن الإنسان العاقل
انتهت مرحلتنا
نحن نعيش أيامنا الأخيرة
وسوف ندخل مرحلة الإنسان الإله
الذي هو الإنسان الذكي
الذي يختلط فيه التقني بالبيولوجي
نحن مطوّرون بيولوجيًّا
ليس الروبوت، بل نحن الكائنات الإنسانية
هذه يُسمى الإنسان الإله
الذي هو الإنسان ما بعد الإنسان العاقل
الذي هو نحن
هو يقول نحن عشنا 100 ألف سنة
قتلنا من قبلنا
يعتبرنا نحن، بكلامه..
وهو كلام شخص طريف ومهرطق
مجنون يعني، لديه أشياء تضحك
وممتع
وطبعًا هو ملحد وعنده مشاكل كثيرة
ولكن من باب الإنصاف
فهو يقول نحن قتلنا الإنسان الذي قبلنا
الإنسان النياندرتال، نحن الذين قتلناه
فيقول نحن أبناء القتلة، نحن أحفاد القتلة
ولكن انتهى وقتنا
الوقت انتهى
نحن في أيامنا الأخيرة
وسيأتي هذا الإنسان الجديد
الذي يسميه هو، الإنسان الإله
وهو الذي تحدّث عنه نيتشة
بالإنسان السوبر مان
نيتشه يذم الإنسان الغربي
ويسميه الإنسان الأخير
لماذا يسميه الإنسان الأخير؟
يقول لأنه تخلّى عن المسيحية، وأصبح ملحدًا
ولكن بقيت فيه القيم المسيحية
يقول هذا الإنسان الضعيف
الذي فيه القيم المسيحية
والذي تخلّى عن المسيحية
وبقيت فيه
وأننا بصدد الانتقال إلى إنسان
ما وراء الخير والشر
ما وراء الأخلاق، في كتابه
ما وراء الأخلاق، يعني قصده
أن نصل إلى مرحلة لا يفكر الإنسان فيها
بقيمتيّ الخير والشر
يتخلى عنهما
وطبعًا هذا مستحيل
لا يمكن أن يتخلى الإنسان عن هاتين القيمتين
مهما زعم
فهو يقول أن الإنسان السوبر مان
سينطلق من قيم القوة
قيم اقتصادية
أو لنقل، عند نيتشه القيم الحيوية
قيم التدفق، والتلذّذ، والانطلاق، والتشبع
هذه المعاني
طبعًا هي قيم حيوانية، واضح
ليست مذمومة في ذاتها
ولكن تعلوها قيم أهم منها، توجّهها
المعنى الجديد الذي تحدّث عنه
هراري نوح، والآخرون هؤلاء
ما يُسمى بنادي الألهة الجديدة
هؤلاء يتحدثون عن هذا الإنسان الإله
الذي فيه هذه القوة
قبل قليل نحن تحدثنا عن فكرة فقدان التسمية
وأن هذه أحد مظاهر هذا الحدث الجديد
الإنسان الإله، الذي يرى نفسه إلهًا
من مظاهرها العجيبة
طبعًا مفهوم الخير والشر
وكل هذه، ملاحظة وواضحة
التقييمات السائدة في العالم
من تجلياتها العجيبة والصادمة
هي إعادة النظر في الموت
فكرة أننا سنتحدى الموت
البشر في يوم من الأيام لم يتحدوا الموت
كان التحدي المشهور للموت عند القدماء
هو ببناء ذكرى
أن تكون بطلًا من الأبطال
عن اليونان مثلًا فكرة البطولة
وأن التاريخ يحفظ سردياتك
ولذلك عنوا بالتاريخ والقصة والأسطورة
وكان دائمًا الذكر الحسن
هو للإنسان عمرٌ ثانٍ، كما يقول الشاعر
الجماعة الآن، لا، يعني ما عاد هذا يكفي
الحديث الآن على..
أن ما هو الموت؟ الموت هو موت الخلايا؟
تمام، سنطوّر هذه الخلايا
سندخل التقنيات الجديدة
بالتطور الحديث، ونتحدى ونجعل الخلية تمتد
نرفع مستوى العمر المتوسّط، عمر الإنسان
شيئًا فشيئًا، ونتطلع إلى أن نصل
لمرحلة من المراحل
لا يموت إنسان. يُقتل؟ نعم يُقتل
ممكن أن تأتي لشاب وتقتله
هذا لا نستطيع أن نوقفه
لكن ما نتحدث عنه، كما يقولون
أننا سنصل لمرحلة نؤخّر موت الخلايا
وبالتالي موت الإنسان
شوف كيف التطلّع، وكأن الموت ليس يقينًا
لا شك فيه، كما يقول الأول
يعني تحقّق قول الحسن البصري
في مقولته العجيبة الخالدة
يقول ما يقينٌ لا شكّ فيه
أشبه بشكٍّ لا يقين فيه، من الموت
يعني الإنسان القديم، يوقن يقين لا شك فيه
يمكن أن يشك في وجود الإله
لكن لا يشك بالموت
يعني يقين
اسمه اليقين، هو مصير محتوم
ويتعامل معه وكأنه شك
وكأنه غير موجود
الآن، لا الموضوع ما هو تعامله
الآن في تحدٍّ حقيقي، نحن سوف نتحدى هذا
نتيجة لهذه الفكرة، في حين لو أن الإنسان
حافظ على رتبة قيمه التي توجهه
التي نسيمها نحن القبلة
نحن نسميها قبلة
يعني له قبلة
مفهوم القبلة، في الفقه مفهوم مادي
اتجاه إلى..
ولكن في المجال الأخلاقي والروحي، نستمد منه
أن هذا مفهوم فطري في داخلنا
نحن لدينا وجهة، والذي هو المعنى
هذه المشكلة الكبيرة
التي نتحدث عنها، هي المعنى، هي القبلة
إذن لدينا اتجاه، والقبلة هي هذه المعاني
الراسخة أمامنا، ونتجه إليها
فالإنسان لديه ميزة، أنه مادام داخل
هذا الاتجاه، نسميه الصراط
الصراط المستقيم
يقول بعض أهل اللغة أن الصراط
يعني لأنه يصرط، يعني يأكلك
يعني يتولى الطريق عنك، أنت دخلت فيه
خلاص
أنت بس شغّل الإلكتروني، ويذهب بك
فهو يقول لك أن هذا الاتجاه
ميزة القبلة، أنك قد تضعف، تنحرف
لكنك ترجع، فمهما ذهبت، ترجع
تنسى، تضل، مخارج خطأ، لكنك ترجع في النهاية
هنالك طريق واضح، لوحات واضحة
فطرية، ثابتة فيك، لا تتغيّر
تقول لك هذا هو الحق
هذا هو الخير، هذا هو الجمال
وهذا هو الشر، وهذا هو القبح
هذا هو الباطل
مهما حدث، لا يمكن لأي عملية أن تقوم بغسلها
قد ينسى
تصيبه الأهواء
نعم. ولكن في النهاية...
ولذلك يقول ابن تيمية كلمة جميلة
يقول: الإنسان ينسى
ولكنه عند أدنى تذكّر يتذكّر
مجرد أن تقول هذا الرجل
الذي قلت قبل قليل أنه...
في ثقافة أخرى يدافع عن البخل
ولا يسميه بُخلًا، يسميه تدبيرًا أو إمساكًا
عندما يرى شخصًا يعطي الآخرين
فلو أنه يرى إنسان يعطي حيوانًا
سيشعر بأن هذا شيء جميل
تهفو إليه..
تتحرّك عنده حاسة الشوق والسوق
لأنه يريد أن يفعل مثله
فقيمة هذه المعاني أننا نرجع
في حين إذا فقد الإنسان هذا الاتجاه
إذا أخذ المخرج...
فما ندري وين يروح
كأنه شخص جديد في الرياض، أخذ مخرج وتورّط
فهذه فكرة القيم، القيم معانٍ راسخة فينا
وأنا أذكر أنني ضربت مثل عن موضوع القيمة
وهو أن هذه القيم ثابتة فينا، ما الدليل؟
الدليل أنّه..
هناك ما يُسمى بمفهوم العوالم الممكنة
أنك تفترض عالمًا ممكنًا
هو مفهوم منطقي ورياضي
فتفترض أنك تعيش فيها
لو أنك عشت في عالم ممكن
لا توجد فيه دائرة، فلا تستطيع أن تتخيلها
لا يمكن
خاصية الإبداع عندنا لا تنتجها
لأن الإبداع يأخذ من المخيلة
المخيلة تأخذ من الذاكرة
الذاكرة تأخذ من الحس
تأخذ من الحس
الحس يحوّلها إلى ذاكرة
والذاكرة تنقلها إلى المخيلة
والمخيلة هي التي تعطي الإبداع
فنحن لا نبدع شيء من لا شيء
حتى لو أتينا بمخلوق مركّب
نركّبه من أشياء موجودة في عالمنا
فإذا ذهبت إلى عالم ممكن ما فيه دائرة
فلا يمكن أن تخطر على بالك
أو ما فيه مربع، أو ما فيه أرقام
لا يمكن أن تخطر على بالك
وذلك مثلًا، وكتقريب
بعض المجتمعات المغلقة، القبائل المغلقة
التي لديها لغة
ستجد أنها لا تعرف بعض المفاهيم خارج اللغة
فكرة العالم الممكن قريب من هذا
لكنك لو ذهبت إلى عالم ممكن
لا يوجد فيه رحمة أو محبة أو حرية
ستظل متشوّقًا إليها، حتى لو لم ترها
بل أحيانًا في بعض المجتمعات غير موجودة
يعني بعض المجتمعات، لا توجد...
مثلًا بعض المجتمعات لا يوجد فيها الكرم
كتقليد عام، أو لا يوجد فيها الرحمة
أو الرأفة أو المحبة الخالصة، لا توجد عندهم
ولكن الإنسان
يتشوّف، ويتشوّق، ويسوق نفسه
يعني هذا الشوق يسوقه، هي حواس بداخلنا
حاسة سَوق، تسوقنا سَوقًا إلى هذه المعاني
الدليل أنها ليست من عالمنا
لأن المعاني التي نأخذها من هذا العالم
قابلة للتغيير والتطوير والتوظيف
وهي المعاني الرياضية هذي
ولذلك بعض العلماء يقولون
أن الرياضيات ليست علمًا
وإنما هي جهاز نظر
جهاز ابتكره الإنسان، يقرأ من خلاله العالم
يتخلى ربما عن الحروف
التي فيها المعاني
الحروف فيها معانٍ، أليس كذلك؟
الكلمات فيها معنى
فيتخلى عنها ويذهب إلى الرياضيات
من حيث أنها لا يوجد فيها معاني
هي مجرّد قوالب يضع فيها الأشياء
فيقرأ فيها العالم
ليس فيها معنى
في حين أن هذه المعاني..
هذه المعاني، هذه القيم، هذه الفضائل
مُشبعة
هي المعنى
وليست مشبعة بالمعنى
هي المعنى أساسًا
فنحن كائنات مشبعة بالمعنى
وجاءت الأديان وزادتنا إشباعًا وتذكيرًا
وأعطتنا الوسائل التي من خلالها
ننميها ونفعّلها
ونبعدها عن الخمول، وإنما نجعلها نشطة
وتؤثر في حياتنا، وتصبح هي الواجب
الذي يؤثّر على هذا الواقع
باختصار، القيم هي معانٍ فطرية
القيم
سواء سميتها قيمة أو سميتها أخلاقًا
أو سميتها فضيلة
أو سميتها معاني، هي معانٍ فطرية
مفطورون عليها نحن، وليست غريزية
وإنما هي معانٍ فطرية
طيب النقطة الثانية
كنت ذكرت أنت
تراتب الأخلاق
بأنه إنسان..
رجولة
مروءة
فتوة
فهل الإنسان هنا فقط الذكر؟
لا طبعًا
فإذن المرأة تصير رجل؟
لا
الإنسان ليس الذكر
الإنسان مفهوم مشترك
الحين لو جيت للـ «Human»
مفهوم الإنسانية، هو يعتمد على كلمة «Man»
وحتى الـ «Wman» تعتمد على كلمة «Man»
يعني الـ «Human» والـ «Wman»
تعتمد على الـ «Man»
ولذلك
هذي، سبيفاك كتبت مقالة، أرسلها لي مختص
تتحدث عن هذا
كيف أن اللغة قائمة على مركزية..
في حين أن نحن، لا
الإنسان ليس...
منسوبة إلى القيمة؟
القيمة
قيمة الأنس
وقيمة الأنس
قيم مشتركة
وهذا هو المعنى...
هذا هو أصلًا الفكرة الرئيسية
أن مفهوم الآدمية، ومفهوم البشرية
ومفهوم الإنسانية
هو مفهوم مشترك لهذا الكائن
الذي هو مكوّن من ذكر وأنثى
كلاهما إنسان
ولذلك حتى في الخطاب الشرعي مثلًا
فهو يخاطب الجميع
لا يميّز، الخطاب الذي يوجّه، يكون للجميع
وأحيانًا يخص ويقول من ذكرٍ أو أنثى
لأنه خطاب مشترك، لا فرق، وهذه ميزة القيمة
الإحالة على فروق أو تمايزات مادية
تفضي إلى عدم المساواة
لا بد أن تفضي إلى عدم المساواة
لأن الواقع ليس متساويًا
ما الذي يدفع الواقع إلى أن يتساوى؟
هو القيم المتساوية
من حقّق هذه القيم تساوى
في حين أن الواقع غير متساوٍ
وهذه الحركة، حركة اليقظة هذه
التي تحاول أن تقول لا، نحن متساوون
ولكن الآخرون يقولون...
خصوصًا علماء البيولوجيا
وعلماء الجينات
يرفضون، ليست متساوية
يرون أن هناك واقع ليس متساويًا
لا نستطيع أن نفرضها فرضًا
العلم هو السيد
يقولون هكذا العلم هو السيد
نحن نقول ليس العلم هو السيد
لأن العلم ينتمي إلى عالم الذكاء
عالم العقلانية والعقل
نحن نقول السيد هو القيم
التي تسود، والتي يجب أن تحكم
هي القيم
التي فيها العدل والرحمة والمحبة والإحسان
وهذه المشكلة
أنه لا أحد، نظريًّا، يقول غير صحيح
نعم، نحن نحتاج إلى هذه المعاني
لكن عمليًّا
لا يتجهون إليها
لأن الإنسان لا يرغب بأن يساويه الآخرون
يريد أن يتمايز عنهم
نعم، تتمايز بقرارك، بإرادتك
وليس بشيء رغمًا عنك
العناصر الحيوية ليست بيدك، أليس كذلك؟
العناصر البيولوجية ليست بيدك
ولكن المساواة التي تتفرّع عن حريتك وإرادتك
هو هذا، هو القرارات التي تتخذها أنت
في الجانب الأخلاقي، بشكل أساسي
وأيضًا في جوانب أخرى
مثل الجوانب الإبداعية، والجوانب الإنتاجية
وكلها ترجع إلى الجوانب النفعية
وميزة الجوانب القيمية
أن مقولتي الخير والشر
تشمل كل المجالات الأخرى
حتى إنتاج الإنسان في الجانب الإبداعي
يشمله الخير والشر
في الجانب الاقتصادي، يشمله الخير والشر
في الجانب السياسي، في الجانب العلمي
في الجانب الاجتماعي
في كل الحقول
في الجانب الأدبي، كل الحقوق الأخرى تخضع
لمقولتي الخير والشر
فكأن الإنسان ليس في لحظة من اللحظات
ينفصل عن هذه المقولة
الأخلاق ليست أفعالًا محدودة
تأتيها أو تتركها
الأخلاق هي هذا المعنى الشامل
الذي يحقّق مقولة الخير للإنسان
يحقّق مقولة الخير ويبعده عن الشر
فإذن، مقولة الإنسان، هي نعم، مقولة مشتركة
فإذن الرجل إذا اكتسب أخلاقًا معيّنة
أصبح رجلًا
بالضبط
والأنثى إذا اكتسبت أخلاقًا معيّنة
أصبحت رجلة؟
أصبحت مرأة
بس أنت أعطيت أن الرجل هو المعيار
لا، ليس معيارًا، هو رتبة
رتبة الرجل، فهي ما تجي لـ ....
نحن نتحدث ونتمركز حول المفهوم
من حيث هو لغة، لغويًّا
لكن لو أردنا أن يتمحور حديثنا
حول الدلالة اللغوية
مع أن الأصل الذي نتحدث عنه هو القيمة
الدلالة اللغوية، يمكن تقول أن المرأة
إذا كانت معاني الذكورة فيها الصلابة
والخشونة، والمواجهة
قد لا تحتاجها المرأة
فبالتالي هي لا تحتاج هذه الرتبة
تقفزها مباشرة
أو أن كمالها..
كما قلت لك هي ليست مراحل
أنا لن أصل إلى المروءة
من خلال المرور بالرجولة
ممكن الإنسان مباشرة تكون لديه الفتوة
ومباشرة تكون لديه المروءة
ويتقلب بينهما، فكذلك المرأة
قد لا تحتاج أن تكون..
فتصبح مرأة؟
بالضبط
يعني من الناحية اللغوية هي مرأة
بغض النظر عن التزامها
كما الرجل، كثير من الناس يُسمى رجلًا
وهو ليس رجلًا، ونحن نطلق على الشخص مرءًا
وهو ليس مرءًا
لم يحقق المروءة، لكن نحن نتحدث
كما قلت، في البداية، نتحدث عن منظور
أخلاقي، تأويل أخلاقي لهذه الرتب
لهذه الهوية البشرية
فالرجل إذا صعد من مرحلة الرجولة أصبح مرأة؟
أصبح مرءًا
مرءًا
أنت تحاول أن تحفر لي فخًّا لا أعرف ما هو
-الحاسة عندي تقول أن هناك مشكلة ما
-لا، لا
-الرجل...
- بس أبغى أفهم
إنسان، رجل
مرء، فتى
المرأة
إنسانة، امرأة
فتاة
فيسقط عنها هذا الرأي
هو لا يسقط عنها
ليس بالضرورة
أنا لما قلت سُلّم
أنا قلت منطقيًّا
ولكن عمليًّا
أنت يمكن أن تكون
وأنت إن شاء الله، وأنت لديك من المروءة
ما يجعلك أرفع من مرتبة..
وأحيانًا مثلًا تحتاج أنت لفكرة..
مثلًا الرجولة في القتال
فتقول هذا رجل ثابت في القتال
وربما في ذلك المقام، تحديدًا
تكون هذه القيمة أبرز
قد تكون أبرز
ولكنه في نفس الوقت
لا تعني أنه يتخلّى عن..
ولذلك لا حظ
قد يكون الرجل شيخ كبير، وهو فتى
يعني نحن ابتعدنا عن المعنى
البيولوجي أو الحيوي
الذي قلنا فيه أن الفتى من بعد الطفولة
إلى فترة الكهولة بعد الأربعين
ويمكن للإنسان أن يظلّ
محافظًا على فتوته وهو بسن أعلى
هناك معنًى طريف، لا بأس من الإشارة إليه
ليس لصيقًا، ولكن..
الفتى، كما قلنا، هو هذا اللين
الفتى هو الغض الليّن
الذي لم يخشوشن بعد
وبالتالي، فالقيم نفس الشيء، غضّة دائمًا
كما قلت لك قبل قليل، غضة
لا تنفصل، لأنها من عالم الروح
يقولون أن المطر
ميزته هكذا، أنه يأتي غضًّا جديدًا
فبالي فيه هذه البركة
ويقولون الطفل سُمي طفلًا
ليس كما يُشاع، أنه من الطفيلي
وإنما من المطر، المطر يُسمى طفل
فكأن الطفل هو مطر جديد، يعني معنًى جديدًا
بل أنا قرأت لبعض الفقهاء معنًى طريف
في الصيام يقولون أنه يستحب
أن تأكل رطبًا وليس تمرًا
لاحظ الرطب يعني رطبًا جديدًا
فيقولون لماذا؟
قالوا لأنه جديد
يعني كأنه ما زال من عالم الروح
صحيح أن هذه معانٍ بعيدة، ولكن..
هناك شفافية معينة في الحقل الأخلاقي
إذا دخلته، رأيت أشياءً لا تراها في...
وتبصر أشياء لا تبصرها في مكان آخر
تنكشف لك عين القلب، وليس عين الرأس
تنكشف لك عين القلب، وترى معاني
شفّافة، وعلى مستوًى من الجماليات العُليا
يتحدثون عن هذه التمرة بأنها جديدة
يعني رطبة، غضة، من عالم الروح
لم يخترقها الزمن، ولم تخشوشن، ولم تشيخ
وكذا وكذا
فيمكن أن يُقال الفتى نفس هذا المعنى
أن هذا الفتى الغض
يتناسب مع هذه القيم الغضة، خارج الزمن
ولاحظ أنها أورثت هذا الفتى استمرار فتوته
حتى لو أن الزمن أفضى به إلى الكهولة
والشيخوخة
مادام محافظًا على هذه المعاني
ظلّ فتًى
لاحظت هذا المعنى الجمالي الرفيع؟
ونحن نعرف أن أفق الأخلاقيات
في نهاية المطاف، يفضي إلى أفق أرفع منه
وهو أفق الجماليات
الجماليات بمعناها القديم، الجماليات العليا
التي تجعل الإنسان كائنًا جماليًّا
من كل النواحي
لاحظ أن فكرة التطهر، التي أشرنا إليها
سواءً في التقديس، في مفهوم القداسة
أو في مفهوم الطهارة أو النزاهة
هو معنًى حسّي
يدخل فيه المعنى الحسّي، والمعنى الباطن
فالتطهر في الظاهر، له أثر على الباطن
وهذه الميزة في الجماليات في تراثنا
أنها لا تنفصل
أنا قلت لك أن هؤلاء الجماعة
أظهروا مفهوم الاستاطيقا بسبب هذا الانفصال
بين البعد المعنوي الجمالي
والجماليات الحسية
في حين أننا نحن لا نفصل بينهما
بل لدينا مفهومًا طريفًا
وهو أن الحس بالنسبة إلينا
ليس حسًّا ظاهرًا فقط
بل حس ظاهر وباطن
ونعتبر الحس الباطن كالحس الظاهر
أن الإنسان يجد هذه المعاني في داخله
ويحس فيها، يحس في إنكاره الكذب
ومحبته للصدق، كما يحس بهذه الأشياء
التي أمامه
نفس الحس واحد
هذا حس باطن، وهذا حس في الظاهر
فقيمته واحدة
حتى أن بعض المعاصرين جعلوه دليلًا
«بلانتينقا» هذا، فيلسوف الأديان
استخدم هذا كدليل في البحث الإلهي
في حين أننا نحن نستخدمه منذ مدة طويلة
ونعتبر أن الحس مصدر من مصادر المعرفة
الظاهر منه والباطن
هناك معرفة باطنة من خلال هذا المصدر الحسي
طيب، فأنت في تعريفك للرجل
وضعته في درجة من درجات..
الهوية الإنسانية، نعم
الأصفهاني يقول أن الرجل
مختص بالذكر من الناس
ومثلًا تلقى في الحديث
لعن الله المترجّلات من النساء
كيف نقدر نربط ما بين الثنتين؟
تعرف أن في اللغة العربية السياقات
معنًى أساسي، يعني نحن نتحدث
عن المعنى الذي يفيده السياق
والمتحدث
فهناك السياق اللغوي نفسه
وهناك السياق التداولي، يعني الشخص نفسه
مثلًا السياق القرآني
المتحدث هو الله سبحانه وتعالى
نعرف حديثه، دلالاته
غير لما يتحدث شخص
مثلًا شاعر جاهلي، فله سياق معيّن
فالأصفهاني طبعًا هو من الفلاسفة الأخلاقيين
الذين لهم عناية كبيرة في الأخلاق
في كتابه الذريعة
وفي عموم كتبه، وهو لمّا يتحدث عن الرجولة
بهذا المعنى
ربما نظر إلى المعنى اللغوي المُستعمل
وبالفعل
نحن نقول أن المرأة لا توصف بهذا المعنى
المعنى الرجولي، إلا في بعض اللغات
كذلك نقول أن المرأة، الاسم الذي استقرّ لها
على من هو المرأة؟
تحدثنا عن الناحية الأخلاقية
أنا أود أن نتذكر دائمًا
نحن نتحدث ضمن منظور أخلاقي
قد يستغرب أحيانًا الشخص
يقول كيف؟ نحن اتفقنا في البداية
أن الإطار الذي ننظر فيه
ونتحدث، ونحلل ونفلسف هذه المعاني
هو عبر الأداة أو العدة الأخلاقية
أصبحت الأخلاق أداة تحليل بالنسبة لنا ههنا
فنقول أن المرأة، نعم، لا توصف بأنها رجلة
لأنها ستأخذ معاني ضد ما يميّزها
معاني الخشونة، والقتل، والبطش، والقوة
هذه معانٍ توراثتها البشرية
وحتى بيولوجيًّا يدل عليه هذا الأمر
لا مكابرة في هذا
ولا حاجة للمرأة في أن..
بالعكس، أن تتجه المرأة إلى هذا الأمر
كأنها تشعر بنقص
في حين أنها هي في رتبة
إذا تحدثنا عن الأدلة التقريرية
رتبة
أيضًا رفيعة، ليس فيها..
إذا أتيت...
كما قلت لك
إذا ذهبت إلى
الموسوعات، والكتب التي تعرّف الأخلاق
في التراث، أو المعاصرة
الآن هناك موسوعات عظيمة
ابتدعها المعاصرون العرب
في المعاني الأخلاقية
جمعوا فيها المقولات
ستجد مقولات كثيرة جدًّا
لأدباء وشعراء وأخلاقيين ومتصوفة وفقهاء
في تحليل هذه المعاني
طيب لمّا ناخذ بعض الثنائيات
مثل ذكر يقابل أنثى
رجل، امرأة
ذكورة، أنوثة
الرجولة، تجد أن مالها مقابل
إي، بالضبط
وهذا هو حديثنا
أن عمليًّا نحن هذا الذي استقرّ عندنا
وربما هذا منزع بعض التعريفات
عمليًّا، من الناحية العملية
لدينا رجل ولدينا امرأة
فكأننا وضعنا الحد الأدنى للرجل
والحد الأدنى للمرأة
لكن لاحظ أن الحد الأدنى للمرأة
إذا نظرنا إليه، من صلة الاسم
بالرتبة الأخلاقية فستكون أرفع
فكأن الحد الأدنى للمرأة أعلى
وليس أنها قفزت، أو تحتاج
هذا التنبيه الرئيسي، ذكرته قبل قليل
نحن لا نحتاج أن نتدرّج
يمكن للإنسان أن يتجه مباشرة إلى رتب عُليا
بالعكس ربما الأصل فيه أنه أعلى وينزل
فنحن نتحدث عن الرجل، ونتحدث عن هذا الكائن
نعم، ذكر وأنثى
هذا تقسيم حيوي
مادي، مُعترف به، لا أحد ينكره
وهناك فروق حقيقية
وإلا تكون اللغة تفرّق بين ما ليس يتفرّق
واللغة مبناها على الاقتصاد
يعني هي تفرّق، بين الفرق الحقيقي
يعني لا تطلق على متشابهين، مصطلحين
هذه فكرة رئيسية في اللغة، أنها اقتصادية
بمجرد أن نجد اختلافًا، سنجد فرقَا
الاختلاف في اللفظ أو في المبنى
يدل على اختلاف المعنى
أو في المضمون
فإذن، الذكر واضحة دلالته
وهذا الشخص الذي له سمات القوة، والصمود
والعنف، وأقرب للعنف، أقرب للخشونة
وتُستخدم في مواضعها الصحيحة
في حين أن المرأة أقرب للطف
والحنان، والليونة
وأيضًا لها وظيفتها
في تربية الإنسان في البداية
يعني أنها تنقل إليه هذه القيم
فلو أن طفلًا منذ البداية
عاش في وسط شدّة وحرب، لأضرّ به
لكنه في البداية يحتاج أن يعمّق
هذه المعاني، معاني اللطف الليونة
فهذه معانٍ، البشرية...
نرجع لموضوع التقليد، الذي تحدث عنه فرانك
البشرية كانت تسلّم بهذا
وهو ناجع، ومفيد، ونافع
فجأة أُعيد النظر فيه
ولا يوجد مشكلة أن يُعاد النظر
إذا طُرح بديل نافع ومفيد
لكن الموجود ليس كذلك
إلغاء هذه الفروق الحقيقية
على المستوى البيولوجي
لذلك تلاحظ، وأنا لا أريد أن أدخل
في مسار، ما يُسمى بالهوية والجندرية
والنقاشات هذه
انفجار هذه الهويات
بسبب أنها تدخل في منحى حقوقي
ولكن تعرف المقولة المشهورة عند بوفوار
لما قالت أن المرأة لا تولد مرأة
وإنما تصبح، اجتماعيًّا
طيب هو هذا إقرار بأن هذه التقاليد
تحمل هذه المعاني
لتحقّق عند الإنسان هذا المعنى
هي لو قالت أن المرأة لا تولد أنثى
لكان غير صحيح، لكنها تقول لا تولد مرأة
وهذا جميل
لمّا نحن في لغتنا...
ربما هناك مشكلة
لأن «Wman» تُنسب إلى الرجل
لكن بالنسبة لي، المرأة لا تولد مرأة
هذا شيء جميل
يعني لاحظ أن الترجمة لا تنقل المشكلة
لما تقول أن المرأة لا تولد، بل تصبح مرأة
أنا لا أرى أن في هذا مشكلة
لأنها لما تصبح مرأة
فهي تكتسب هذه المعاني
معاني المروءة
لكن بالنسبة لها
وبلغتها، فصحيح. لأنها كأنها تقول
أنها تُنسب للرجل
فلاحظ مشكلة الترجمة، الترجمة لم تنقل
بل فتحت عليّ إشكالات ليست موجودة عندي
أنا ما أشعر أن اكتساب المرأة
لأخلاق المروءة، مشكلة. أليس كذلك؟
بالعكس، هذه ميزة
كما أن أخلاق الفتوة
وأخلاق الرجولة
بسبب مشكلة الترجمة، وبسبب المنظور الأخلاقي
أننا نتخلّى في تحليلنا عن هذا المنظور
لكن برضو في كتاب نضرة النعيم
يقول لك هذي الصفات الأربع
الرجولة والفتوة والمروءة
اللي ما تشوف فيها إشكال
والإنسانية
يرجع اشتقاقها إلى جنس الذكور
شوف، بعض الذين كتبوا
أنا قلت ستجد شيئًا كثيرًا
الأصل هو المفهوم
الأصل في التعريف هو المفهوم
فتقول في قيمة الفتوة مثلًا
تقول أن الفتى مشتق من الفتوة، وليس العكس
نحن نقول أن المرء
ليس أن المروءة مشتقّة من المرء
عندها سنقول وما هو المرء؟
لكن لأننا نعرّف بهذه القيمة
التي سبقت هذا المرء المعيّن
والمطلوب من هذا الإنسان
أن يحقّق هذه المعاني
المعاني التي تسبقه
وليس هو الذي يسبقها
المعاني سابقة له
بالتالي إذا كان يحقّقها، اكتسب هذه الصفة
فكأننا نقول أن هذه الصفة..
ولذلك، هذا السر في البداية
بمفهوم الهوية البشرية
أنت حينما تحقّق معاني الصفات الإنسانية
فأنت تكتسب، ويتحقق فيك المعنى الإنساني
لاحظ مفهوم التحقّق، أصبح حقًّا
وعندما تحقّق المعاني الآدمية
اللي هو الأدمة والألفة، تصبح آدميًّا
وعندما تحقّق أن تكون حسّاسًا
وتظهر فيك معاني البشر وكذا وكذا
فأنت بشريًّا
ونفس الشيء
لما يحقّق الرجل المعاني الرجولية
نقول هو رجل
نحن نطلق عليه رجل حتى لو لم يحققها
هذا عرف، وله دلالة خاصة
ولكن المعنى في الأساس
نحن لماذا نثوّر هذه المعاني ونثيرها؟
لأنها تدلنا
على هذا المنظور الأخلاقي الكامن
وتحمينا من طرح أسئلة لم نطرحها نحن
بل تُفرض علينا فرضًا
هي من ضمن
هذه الإشكالات التي فرضها الآخر علينا
كما قلت لك، لاحظ الفرق بين مقولة
سيمون دي بوفوار، وكيف أنها لها وجه
في لغتها، بينما ليست لها وجه في لغتي
أنا المنظور أخلاقي عندي، وليست تابعة للرجل
في مفهوم الـ «Wman»
فهذه المفاهيم في الحقيقة
أنت تحقّق وصف المرء، إذا حققت المروءة
وتحقق وصف الفتى، إذا أنت حقّقت..
فكذلك المرأة
ربما في بعض الأحيان، وليس كل ما قيل صحيحًا
ربما يخطئون في إعادة...
وهذا الكلام كنت أقوله
قبل أيام مع بعض الأصدقاء
أن بعض من قال أن الأصل هو العكس
أنها أُخذت...
كان الحديث عن موضوع المروءة
أن مفهوم المروءة، أُخذ من المرء والمرأة
أنا قلت العكس، أن في الحقيقة، منطقيًّا
المعنى يسبق، نحن نأخذ
هذه الصفات لهذا الكائن
من هذا المعنى
لدينا كائن حي نريد أن نسميه
ماذا نسميه؟ هل نسميه من منطلق بيولوجي
أونسميه منطلق اقتصادي
الإنسان، هل هو كائن اقتصادي؟
فنسميه رابح أو خاسر
وتاجر وكذا وكذا وكذا؟
أو من منطلق جمالي، أو من منطلق...
ما هو المنطلق؟ سياسي؟
ماذا نسميه؟
مثلًا في المنظور السياسي نسميه مواطن
أو كذا
في المنظور الأخلاقي عندنا هذه التسمية
أنه مرء
نعم، عندنا كريم ولطيف وكذا
ولكن هذه المسميات جامعة
لما نقول المروءة
هي كمال الرتبة التي تسبقها
والفتوة هي كمال الرتبة التي تسبقها
فكأن هناك كمالات معينة نأخذ أقصاها
لكن ما هو الفتى، بحكم المعنى الذي ذكرته؟
سواءً مفهوم عدم اختراق الزمن له
وإن كان يشيخ، ولكنه فتًى
بسبب أخذه للحد الأقصى من المعاني الأخلاقية
يعني هو لم يهتم بالمعنى الأقصى التمتعي
ولا بالمعنى الأقصى العاطفي
ولا بالمعنى الأقصى...
كل المعاني القصوى، التي عادة
يتطرّف فيها الشاب وبعدين يهدأ
في المعنى الأخلاقي، أخذ المعنى الأقصى
ولم يهدأ، استمرّت معه
أصبح معتادًا
بس عشان أفهمك
-لأني إلى هنا بيجي عندي إشكال
-بتساعدني على فهم نفسي
الآن أنت تقول أن المروءة من امرأة
العكس، المسميات..
أن الامرأة من المروءة؟
إيه. المرأه والمرء، لا أريد أن أخصص
أن المرء والمرأة
يستحق هذا المسمى، يحقّق هذا المسمى
أنت يمكن أن تسمي نفسك كريمًا
وتحقّق هذا المسمى، إذا أصبحت كريمًا
واضح؟
المفهوم التحقيقي، مفهوم الحق
الحق يعني الثابت، الراسخ
الحق له عدّة معانٍ
المعنى القانوني، والحق بمعنى ضد الباطل
وهناك المعنى الكياني
أو الوجودي أو الأنطلوجي
كما يقول..
يعني أنت حق، فالواقع حق
أنت أمامي، حق الآن
يعني لست خيالًا
وأنا ما أقول باطل، لا
أنت حق بمعنى أن وجودك حق
فأنت تحقّق من معاني..
تحقق وصف الكرم إذا أصبحت كريمًا
وتحقق وصف الشجاعة، إذا أصبحت شجاعًا
والبطولة..
وتحقق وصف المرء إذا أصبحت ذو مروءة
لديك مروءة
المرء والمرأة يحققون هذا المعنى
ولكن قد لا يحققونه
لأني أقول لك، إن الإنسان يتقلب
واضح
يتقلب، وسيظل اسمه مرءًا
وسيظل اسمها امرأة
وسيظل اسمه فتى وفتاة
وغالبًا سيطلق الناس الفتى والفتاة
على الشباب
يعني الناس ربما
يتناولون مفهوم المرء بقلّة
أغلب الااستعمال هو المرأة أو الرجل
وعلى فكرة، لاحظ أن الاستعمال السائد
لصالح...
أن هذه رتبة أعلى
لكن لو أن هذه الثقافة التحليلية
لو أن الأخلاق ظلّت حاضرة
كأداة من أدوات التحليل
نستخدمها دائمًا في تحليلاتنا
لاحظ كيف نحن نحلل دائمًا
الاقتصاد، والمشاريع
والبرامج، والشركات، والأوضاع
نحلّل
ونادر منا من يستخدم التحليل الأخلاقي
وحتى من يستخدمه
لا يستخدمه بشكل مرتب ومنظم
ومنتج، ومقوّم
وإنما أحيانًا ربما يستخدمه
من أجل تعييب الآخرين أو التقليل من شأنهم
أو كذا
ولكن لما نستخدم، ولما يشيع بيننا
استخدام البعد الأخلاقي
ونعود لهويتنا الحقيقية
ونتحفّظ على الأدوات المنقولة
في تحليل الأشياء
ستجد أنها تختلف الأشياء
نحن الآن نستخدم أدوات مفروضة علينا فرضًا
ما الذي يجعلك تستجيب
إلى هذه الأدوات التي لها سياقها الخاص؟
أنا لا أتحدث الآن عن كونها خطأً
أو صوابًا، في سياقها
لها سياق الخاص
على الأقل سياقها الخاص يفسّر ظهورها
بغض النظر، يفسّر ظهورها
لكن بالنسبة لي، لا يفسر وجودها
ولا تنفعني، ولا تنتج لدي شيئًا
لديّ معايير تجيب عن هذه الأسئلة
وأنا ما عندي مشكلة
أن هذه المعايير المنقولة
أستفيد منها
بشريطة أن أستخدم تجاهها معاييري الخاصة
التي هي معاييري الأخلاقية
ما دام أن هويتي الوجودية
التي هي الهوية الإنسانية
نحن نقول أن الإنسان، في الأساس
الهوية هي وجوده
وماهيته هي صفاته، فهويته الصفاتية هذه
هي التي يجب عليه أن يحمي بها وجوده
فيجعلها معيار، مصدّة
وأدوات فرز، يختبر فيها الأشياء
التي يقبلها والتي يرفضها
أليس لديك جهاز صحي يجعلك تقبل الأشياء
التي تنفعك، وترفض الأشياء التي تضرّك
من أجل وجودك البيولوجي؟
تمامًا، وتعمل به
والعاقل من يحافظ عليه
وكذلك معاييرك الاقتصادية في الربح والخسارة
كذلك هناك معاييرك الخاصة
في وجودك الإنساني، في هويتك الإنسانية
لديك معاييرك
التي تحمي لديك هذا الوجود، وتنميه
ويزدهر ويتفتح وينمو وينتج
أو تتجاهل هذا المعيار تمامًا
وتفتح لمعايير أخرى تفضي بك
إلى تغيير هويتك
هويتك الإنسانية، وما يتفرع عنها
ممتاز، الآن لما تقول..
-ما اكتفينا؟
-ما اكتفينا والله
إذا تسمح لي
أنت تركتني أندفع حتى نشفت
ثم بدأت جولتك الخاصة
طيب، الحين لما تقول، خلك رجّال أو كن رجلًا
على طول حاضر في ذهني صفات كثيرة
لعلّ أغلبها صفات ذكورية
-القوة، الشجاعة، الإقدام، المغامرة
-هي ليست صفات ذكورية
ولكن لنقل أنها الصفات الأخلاقية
التي تناسب الذكر
هي ليست صفات ذكورية
المفروض أن هناك فصل
الذكورة هي وصف حيوي، بيولوجي
ولكن هذه الأخلاقيّات
مثلًا القتال، النجدة، الفزعة
هذه المعاني
بالسياقات الاجتماعية
على الأقل أتحدث في السياقات
الاجتماعية القديمة، كان الذي يظهر
في المجال العام هو الرجل
والذي مهيّأ أن يقوم بهذا، هو الرجل
ولا تُعاب المرأة
يعني لا تُعاب المرأة أنها لا تقوم بهذا
لأنه ليس مجالها
ليست هي حاضرة
لها سياق خاص وكذا
لا أعرف مستقبلًا إذا تغيّرت
سياقاتنا الاجتماعية كيف تكون الأوضاع
أنا أتحدث عن الوضع الذي نشأت فيه اللغة
ونشأت فيه التقاليد السابقة
وأعتقد أن هذه أشياء لن تتغيّر كثيرًا
ربما، الله أعلم
دعني أتحدث عن هذا المعنى القائم
فسابقًا، وصف الرجولة
كانت المعاني الأخلاقية، المرتبطة به
المرتبطة بهذا الرجل الذي يظهر..
بهذا الكائن
الذكر الذي يظهر في المجال العام
هو الأقرب لأن يحقّقها
لكن فيه مجالات أخرى
المرأة تحققها في مجالها
التي هي معاني المروءة
والمعاني الأخلاقية الأخرى كلها
متاحة أن تحققها
بس ليش مثلًا لما تروح للمرأة
يعني لو أقول كُوني امرأة
يعني ما هو حاضر
إذا آخذها بالشكل التداولي
بالضبط
فما هو بحاضر أن كوني كريمة..
يعني هذه الصفات الأخلاقية العليا
-ما يجي
-صحيح
وتقدر تاخذ..
إذا أنت تبغى الصفات اللي ترتبط بالأنثى
فتقول خليك أنثوية
ممتاز
فتشوف أننا ننزع منها
فهل الأنثى ما عندها صفات أخلاقية عالية؟
يعني لنقل أن مثلًا معاني..
معاني الحنان، معاني اللطف، ومعاني العناية
ما يُسمى بأخلاق الأمومة
الرعاية، أخلاق الرعاية
وهذا فرع أخلاقي الآن
تعرف أن بعض فلاسفة أخلاق الأمومة، رجال
لأنهم يرون
أن هذه المعاني الأخلاقية الجديدة
التي يطرحونها
أخلاق العناية والرعاية والأمومة وكذا
أن البشرية بحاجة إليها
بسبب اندفاع البشرية باتجاه بعيد عن..
الاتجاه العلمي
الذي هو اتجاه قاسٍ
بل إن مثلًا هناك اتجاه في الأخلاق
وهو أيضًا مبحث جديد في الأخلاق
هو ليس خلق جديد، لكن قصدي
كبحث فلسفي نظري جديد، هو أخلاق الثقة
أخلاق الثقة
هذه الفيلسوفة النيوزلندية
التي بحثت مفهوم أخلاق الثقة
تقول أنها اجترحت هذا المفهوم
هي تدعي
أنها هي التي اجترحت هذا المفهوم الجديد
وتحاول أن تقول لماذا هذا المبحث جديد؟
يعني أين فلسفة الأخلاقية السابقة عنه؟
لاحظ هذه الأسباب التي تقولها
طريفة جدًّا، وهي نسوية هذه المرأة
هذه الفيلسوفة
فتقول إن الفلاسفة القدماء
تجنّبوا مفهوم الثقة
وركّزوا على مفهوم العقل
كأنها تجعل أن هناك تقابل بينهما
لماذا وضعت هذا التقابل؟
هي تقول أن مفهوم الثقة أقرب للإيمان
في حين أن العقل أقرب للتسليم المادي
يعني التبرير المادي المشاهد
عادةً الفلاسفة يفصلون بينهما أو يقابلون
بدرجات متفاوتة
فهي تقول أن هناك ثلاث أسباب
جعلت هؤلاء الفلاسفة يتجاهلون مفهوم الثقة
ولا يبحثونه أخلاقيًّا
أولًا تقول أنهم مجموعة من الذكور
تقول أنهم ذكوريون
وتقول بهذا الشكل
وطبعًا تطلق الفاظ أخرى، لا يليق أن تُقال
بأنهم ذكوريون وكذا وكذا
وتستثني طبعًا، ستثني واحد أو اثنين
ولكن قصدها الاتجاه العام
عندهم بأنهم ذكوريين
وهذا الذي جعلهم يبتعدون مفهوم الثقة
وإذا انطبق هذا على الفلاسفة الغربيين
فهو لا ينطبق على المسلمين
لأن مفهوم الثقة مركزي جدًّا
من المنظور الأخلاقي عندنا
وهذا موضوع آخر
نتحدث عنها في سياقها
والسبب الثاني تقول
أن مفهوم الثقة
مفهوم يقع في منطقة بين الإيمان والعقل
وفقًا لتحليلها، يقع بين الإيمان والعقل
فبالتالي هو أكمل، لأن فيه عناصر
تبريرية عقلانية، وفيه عناصر...
يعني الثقة غالبًا مبرّرة
وفيه عناصر تسليمية تقوم على الثقة
فتقول بينما هؤلاء الفلاسفة يمركزون العقل
لا يبتعدون عنه
السبب الثالث طريف جدًّا
تقول إذا كان ما سبق عن وعي
فتقول هذا السبب الثالث ليس عن وعي
السبب الثالث
أن الثقة
لصيقة فينا جدًّا جدًّا جدًّا
لدرجة أنها مختفية
أنها لا تُرى
وهذا حق
يعني صفة الثقة من الصفات
التي يسكت الناس عنها
لأنها مسلّمة قصوى
ولذلك لو طرحت سؤالًا على الناس
هل الأصل في علاقتك بالآخرين
هي الثقة أو الشك؟
يختلفون، ستجد ناسًا يقولون الثقة
وناسًا يقولون الشك
وكثير من الناس سيقول الشك
وخصوصًا في بعض المجتمعات
وسيبرّر، ويأتي بقول الشاعر فلان وعلّان
وأن الناس لا يوثق فيهم
والإنسان ذئب أخيه الإنسان
كلمة هوبز
وهكذا
وأن العقد الاجتماعي سببه عدم التوافق
وكان البشر في الحالة الطبيعية
وانتقلوا للعقد الاجتماعي
كلام لا ينتهي، يفترض ضمنيًّا
أنهم ليسوا ثقات
عمليًّا
نحن لا نستطيع أن نعيش لحظة بدون الثقة
عندما نجتمع في مكان واحد
يثق بعضنا في بعض
لا نخاف أن هناك مؤامرة
نشرب الماء، لا نشعر أن فيه مشكلة، والشاي
ربما فقط مشكلة في الطعام
أو في الجودة
لكن لا توجد أي مشاكل في الثقة
أنا ما عندي شك في الجودة
نعم، نعم لا شك في الجودة
تدخل في المطاعم وتأكل مسلّمًا
مطاعم بعيدة في أقصى الدنيا
صحيح
في أقصى الدنيا، أماكن
وتأتي في بلد بعيد
تقف عند الإشارة، تسأل الشخص عن مكان
ويخبرك، وتذهب
لا تناقشه
نعم، قد تأتي...
وهذا يدلك
على مركزية أن الإنسان كائن أخلاقي
هذا يدل على أن هذا الشيء عميق
لدرجة أننا لا نبصره
لا نبصره
تخرج من بيتك، وأنت واثق، الأمور تمام
عندك عاملة تثق فيها، سائق تثق فيه
أبناؤك
تنام مع شخص في البر...
أحيانًا هناك عوامل أكيد تحتاج إلى حذر وحزم
في وقتها
الأصل هو هذا
فهي تتحدث عن هذا المعنى
معنى موضوع الثقة
فالناس أحيانًا تتجاهل بعض المفاهيم
شوف كيف لما يحلّلون موضوع علاقتنا ببعض
ينسون موضوع الثقة
ولكن لو أُثير هذا الموضوع
وتحول إلى أداة تحليل
حاضرة في المجال الثقافي
لاشك أن الناس سيتذكروه
ولا يحتاجون إلى جهد كبير، لأنه موجود فيهم
وأنا هذا الموضوع كلما طرحته في مكان
في البدايات يكون فيه نقاش
في الجلسات العادية مع الأصدقاء
بعدين الكل يسلّم فيه
لأن الكل بالفعل ينتبه
يحدث نوع من اليقظة
أن فعلًا هذا موضوع..
ونفس الشيء
لما تناقش الكثير من المفاهيم الأخلاقية
في البدايات ينازعك الإنسان
لا، موضوع الكرامة
كيف أننا نحن نحتاج..
بمجرد نقاش بسيط يرجع مباشرة
وأنت لاحظت كيف النقاش
مباشرة يتراجع الإنسان
لا يستطيع الإنسان أن ينكر هويته
هذه هويتنا، علينا أن نرفعها بصوت رفيع
هويتنا الإنسانية، هوية أخلاقية
يجب ألا نستسلم لأي أدوات تحليلية أخرى
تحاول أن تهمّش. لأن العواقب كارثية
عواقب تهميش المنظور الأخلاقي
في تقويمنا لأنفسنا، كارثية
ونحن نرى، وهذا أمر مشاهد
فوجود فتور أو ضعف في التناول هذا
سواءً في عاداتنا القديمة..
أنت أوردت أكثر من مثال
لماذا الناس يقولون كذا؟
ويصفون المرأة بالأنوثة؟
ربما هناك تراكم، يحتاج إلى تحليل آخر
نحتاج أن نأخذه شيئًا فشيئًا
تحليل خاص
لكن أنا تحدثت..
هذا الواقع، الذي أنت تذكره هو الواقع
أنا تحدثت من منظور الواجب
من الواجب
الذي إذا كان الواقع فيه قصور
يجب أن ينشدّ إليه
يجب أن نعيد تقويمه
لهذا يرفع الناس أصواتهم بالمنظور الأخلاقي
من أجل أن يشيع، أن يعدّل، أن يقوّم
هذا الوضع
كثير من الآراء المنحرفة تسيد في العالم
ليست عبثًا
جاءت لتحاول معالجة إشكالات في الواقع
لكنها أدّت خطأ
إذا كان الباعث صحيحًا
خصوصًا فيما بعد
لمّا يذهب المؤسسون
وتأتي اتجاهات أخرى
وتأخذ الموضوع كأيديولوجيا
يتحول شيئًا فشيئًا ويبتعد عن أصله
وتُنسى المشكلة الأساسية
في حين أننا نحن، لما نرتبط بالهوية
هويتنا
نحن مازلنا مرتبطين بالمعنى الأول
الذي يعيد فتوتنا
يعني يعيدها بالنسبة لنا غضّة طريّة
مرّة أخرى
أنا ودي أسألك كم سؤال زيادة، بس أخاف أنك..
تحب نكتفي بهذا القدر؟
يعني..
-شكرًا جزيلًا
-شكرًا لك
شكرًا لكم
وشكرًا لوهّاب موسى في التصوير
وتركي القحطاني في إعداد الحلقة
ومحمد الحسن في الهندسة الصوتية
وعبد المجيد العطّاس في التلوين
ومحمد نور شمّت في التحرير
ونورة السبيعي في إدارة محتوى
التواصل الاجتماعي
ومنتج فنجان: أيمن الحمّادي
مدير التحرير: أسيل باعبدالله
هذا فنجان، أحد منتجات
شركة ثمانية للنشر والتوزيع
ننشر كل الإنتاج
بحب
من مدينة الرياض
الأسبوع المقبل
ألقاكم
أنت قلت في بداية الحلقة
أو في وحدة من الأجزاء
أن اليوم صار حضور الهوية أكثر فردانية
إي نعم
بينما اليوم، برضو الشائع
واللي ما أدري، وهذا مجرد ملاحظة
تلقى فيه أن الهويات
أنها بدت...
حتى الجامعة، تلقى الأفارقة
في أمريكا
الأمريكيون الأفارقة، صارت هويتهم
-إيه الهويات الفرعية، الهامشية
-تطغى
فالهويات الهامشية، صارت حاضرة بقوة
وعادت...
يبدو أنها اختفت
فتلقى أنها ما عادها فردانية
بالعكس رجعت الجماعات
هذه أحد النقاشات على الاتجاهات الفردانية
أن دعاة الفردانية ليسوا أفرادًا
الإنسان أساسًا..
يعني مثلًا الاتجاه الليبرالي
ما عاد هو فرد
ولكن في الحقيقة
هذا لا يجب أن يعيمنا
يعني هذه الصفة العامة
لا تعمينا على أن هناك
مكوّنات مركزية، رئيسية
داخل هذا الاتجاه الجمعي، هي فردانية
يعني المعاني التي يتجمّع هؤلاء عليها
هي معانٍ فردانية
فكأنك تقول، ما الفرق بين الجماعة والمجتمع؟
تاتشر تقول ما فيه شيء اسمه مجتمع
فيه أفراد
وهي كلامها صحيح
لأنها لا تنظر إلى هذا الكل المجموع
ليست وحدة مجموعية
الفرق بين المجتمع والجماعة
أن الجماعة، بالفعل، تحقّق معنًى مشتركًا
في حين أن المجتمع، هو مجتمع أفراد
يعني الفرد مركز فيه
صحيح أنهم أفراد
لكن الفرد مركز فيه
فكأن العلاقة اللي تحكم هذا المجتمع
هي علاقة الفرد، تسبق الجماعة
نعم نحن جماعة، ولكن يجب..
وللا أصلًا لو كان الإنسان الفرداني
ليس في جماعة
ما اهتم بفكرة الفردانية
هو مشكلته مع الفردانية
أنه وسط جماعة
فيقول يا جماعة أنا فرد
أنا فرد، ويجب أن تتعاملوا معي على أني فرد
في حين أن..
رجعنا نصوّر؟
في حين أن الجماعة
تنطلق من لا أولية الجماعة
أن نعم، أنت جزء منا، ولكن أنا وأنت
كوّنا..
أنا وأنت لسنا اثنين أو ثلاثة، في الحقيقة
وهكذا، فهذا الفرق
فهذا هو معنى أن الفردانية حاضرة بشكل رئيسي
حتى لو قيل أن
الاتجاهات التي تنادي بها، مجموعية
وحتى كون المروءة نسبية، تختلف من وقت لوقت
أتوقع أن من خوارم المروءة أنك تاكل
قدام أحد، أو شي زي كذا، زمان؟
نحن الآن لسنا في مجال...
بناكل مع بعض لازم
يعني فيه حد أدنى بيولوجي، لازم نحافظ عليه
وللا ما عاد يكون للأخلاق..
فيه واحد اسمه ستينقر
هذا فيلسوف حي، موجود
رجل طاعن في السن، أتوقع عمره 82 سنة
هذا الرجل أخلاقي، وأصلًا تخصّصه أخلاق
هو فليلسوف أخلاق
تخصصه في الأخلاق العملية والبيئية
وهو مشهور بأنه فيلسوف الحيوان
يدافع عن الحيوانات
يعني جيدة
ولكنه يرفع
شوف موضوع حركة اليقظة
هو ليس نسويًّا
ولكنه يرفع ويساوي الإنسان بالحيوان
لدرجة أنه يقدم مثلًا
بعض الحيوانات
مثلًا على الرجل المريض، العجوز
يقول ما عاد له كفاءة نفعية
لأنه يدخل هو المعايير النفعية
فخلاص يجوز قتله أو التخلص منه
ويقدم عليه مثلًا الحيوان المفيد
مثلًا هو يرى قتل الطفل الذي يولد مريضًا
والغريب أن هذا، على مكانته الكبرى
وهو فيلسوف
في الحقيقة، يحقّق وصف الفلسوف التقني
يتعامل معه الأساتذة والطلاب في الجامعات
على أنه شرير
شرير
تخيل!
وظل لفترة طويلة
لا يُستقبل في الجامعات
وما تعيّن في جامعة بيركلي إلا مؤخّرًا
يمكن قبل عشر سنوات، يعني بعد السبعين
طول عمره يُرفض، يذهب لفرنسا
وتخيل، بريطانيا
يجد اللافتات أمامه
ويُرمى بالبيض
ولا يُستقبل
وتحتج الطلبة على الجامعات
حتى ما يوظفونه
بسبب مقولات البشعة هذه، ويدافع عنها
وقيل له مرة في مؤتمر
قال له شخص يناقشه
مسكين، صار عنده عار
ولكن طاق صدره وما عليه من أحد
فيناقشونه فيها، فقالت له واحدة
بس أنت بهذا المعنى، أنت تجيز
تزاوج الحيوان بالإنسان
ما دام أنهم من رتبة واحدة
فهو ما أنكرها
وصحيح أنه ما كتبها، بس ما أنكرها
لأنه بالفعل لا يوجد حد
فكرة التقدم...
يعني حلّاق مرة قال أن أضخم فكرة
الآن مسيطرة بالعقل الغربي، هي فكرة التقدم
اللي قرأوه قالوا مبالغة
ليست مبالغة، لا توجد قيم ثابتة إلا التقدم
معناه، اصنع كل شيء
وأنت لما تقول أن التقدمية تيار
يدخل فيها أشياء كثيرة من كل الأطراف
سياسية، اجتماعية، أخلاقية
كل شيء، كل شيء
ولكن الموجّه الرئيسي فيه
هو: يجب أن نتجاوز
طيب، لازم ننجاوز الأخلاق إذن
الأخلاق هي مكان ثابت، مفهوم ثابت لا يتغيّر
يجب أن نتجاوزه
وللا ما يكون فيه تقدّم
نحن كنا نقول يجب أن نتمسك بالأخلاق، ونتقدم
ولاحظ النتيجة الخطيرة
أف! كيف فاتتنا قبل شوي؟
هذا اللي إذا تناقشت مع شخص
تذكرت الرد بعدين
شوف هذه الفكرة، أن التقدم الأخلاقي
اللي يدل على أنه سيفضي إلى شر
أنه انفلت عن الأخلاق، لأنه ما عاد يُعايَر
ولذلك تشوف مثلًا الأسلحة وكذا
واترك الحين
ما عاد الحين الأسلحة
الآن في الذكاء الصناعي
أصبحوا يتحدثون على أنه خطر أخلاقي
لماذا؟ لأن التقدم إذا انفلت من الأخلاق
سيكون شر، التقدم قوة
والشرير الأقوى
أشد من الشرير الضعيف، أليس كذلك؟
صحيح
سيكون الشر مضاعفًا
وقويًّا، ونافذًا، وعميقًا
وراسخًا، وله السلطة العليا
في حين لو أن هذا التقدم
كان معه تقدم روحاني وأخلاقي
لأصبحت البشرية في أمان
بالعكس هذا المطلوب
مطلوب أن نزيد...
لدرجة أن بعض العلماء
ولا أدري هل هي شطحة أو لا
يقول أصلًا نماذج الأنبياء
في الطب
ومثلًا سليمان..
الرجل الذي طوى شهرين، الذي أتاه
قال هذه النماذج
وضعها القرآن لكي نسعى لتحقيقها
أن يللا، هذه النماذج
يللا، شدوا حيلكم
ولكن شدوا حيلكم
وأنتم تعبدون الله
وأنتم متمسكون بهذه التوجيهات
فإذن، بالعكس
إذا صحّ كلامه
وهذا كلام ابن عربي
ان عربي الصوفي
في الفتوحات المكية
إذا صح كلامه
هذا معنى أن نحن نتطلّع بالتقنية
لأبعد مما وصلنا إليه
لسّة، قدامنا طريق، وشرعًا نحن نتطلع إليه
النبوات جاءت لتعطينا نماذج
بناءً على كلامه
لنفترض أن كلامه صحيح
لكن يجب أن يكون هذا مشدودًا
بالعكس، كأن النموذج النبوي يقول
لا يلزم أن تصل لتلك المراحل
أن تنقل الأشياء بلحظة
مثل ما حصل لسليمان
أو مثلًا يقف الماء، كما حدث لموسى
أو...
تعرف أن الأشاعرة
يجعلون هذه المعاني قابلة للتحقّق
ومذهبهم إلى حدٍّ كبير صحيح في السببية
إلى حد كبير صحيح
الآن العلم الحديث لا يقوم على السببية
بالمعنى القديم
يقوم على القانون
العلم الحديث
فإذا كان للبشر أن يحقّقوا
هذه المعاني
وبالفعل استطاعوا أن يصلوا إليها
كما يحثهم عليها القرآن، بطريقة غير مباشرة
فالقرآن يقول نعم، تستطيعون أن تصلوا إليها
بدون أن تتخلوا عن أخلاقياتكم وإنسانيتكم
ترى هذه المعاني ليست ثقافية
هذه المعاني تحدٍّ كبير
يعني كارثة أن تكون الأخلاق ثقافة
لأنك لما تقول الأخلاق ثقافة
معناها أن الأخلاق لم تعد في واقعك
ولست في دينك، قطعت علاقتك بالدين
وليست في الواقع
لأن الواقع قائم على السياسة، وسلطة الواقع
وليست فطرة، لأنه ليس هنالك فطرة
فإذن ما أصبح للأخلاق قيمة
إلا وين؟
في الثقافة
الثقافة كلها ما فيها مشكلة
أعلى ثقافة موجودة في تاريخ الكون كله
موجودة في فرنسا وبريطانيا وأمريكا وألمانيا
بين كتب لا تُعد ولا تُحصى، ومجلات
ليس لها قيمة
بس وش يهمك
أو حتى مُفترض عادي، نقبل بالتقدم
بأقصى سرعة
وما هي مشكلة، إذا كان الأصل في الفطرة
زي ما أنت تقول
أن الأخلاق فطرة
فكذا كذا، راجعين لها
لا، ليس كذلك. هو الأخلاق ميزتها أنها حرّة
هي فطرة صحيح، ولكن فطرة كمادة خام
أنت تشوف مثلًا موضوع الكرم
الإنسان من كماله أن يعطي
إذا بمنطقها منطقيًّا، سأقولها بهذا الشكل
أنت ناقص
فإذا اكتملت، بدأت تتعدّى
يعني أنا كائن قاصر على ذاتي
جيد؟
إذا بدأت أفيض
بدأت أتعدّى ذاتي
تعدي الغير...
إذا تعدّى نفعي الغير
أصبحت كاملًا
فأنا أعطي الغير حتى أنا أكون كاملًا
أليس كذلك؟
وهذا صحيح بالنسبة لنا نحن البشر
ليس بالضرورة، ممكن أن أعطي غيري
وأنا ناقص
ولكنها دلالة على الكمال، لماذا؟
لأن الأكمل، وهو الله سبحانه وتعالى
هو الذي يعطي غيره
العطاء الإلهي دليل على كمال، كمال الإله
فنحن نفس الشيء، كرمنا وعطاؤنا
سعينا في أن نكتمل
لكن لا نفعل هذا، لا نفعل هذا
رغم أننا نعرف أن هذا كمال
وأنت لما ترى إنسانًا يعطي حيوانًا
تراه كمالًا
وإذا يعطي فقيرًا تراه كمالًا
وهذا ستينقر، بالمناسبة
من الأشياء العظيمة اللي حببتني فيه
هو هذه، فكرة العطاء
تخيّل، يقول أنك أنت..
مثال عجيب، يقول أنه سوّى حسبة
لما تشرب ماء الصحة
في بيتك كل يوم
ولما تشرب هذا الماء، كأس
وصل الفرق بالتكلفة
بعد ما أدري كم، أنك أنت حرمت
فقراء كانوا يمكن أن يحتاجوا إلى هذا الماء
أو إلى تكلفته
وعددهم كذا وكذا
ومات عددهم كذا
وفعل كذا
وكان الطلاب ينصدمون
يدخل الأساتذة على طلاب في الجامعة
ويقول لهم هذه المقدمة، وينصدمون منه
نتائج فظيعة، كأنك تشعر بالذنب وأنت تأكل
أو تشرب ماء صحة
لماذا؟ كان يتحدث عن هذه القيمة
شوف أن ممكن الإنسان يتفكك، ويتيه
بالتعامل الأخلاقي
الشاهد، أنك أنت أخلاقيًّا
أنت حر، يمكن ما تستمع
وهذا هو الذي يحدث
المشكلة أن الروبوت لا توجد فيه فطرة
إذا صدق هذا الشيطان في كلامه
وأنا ما أدري يصدق أو ما يصدق
ونجح البشر في الفصل بين الذكاء والوعي
والله أكلنا هواء
أكلنا هواء
لأن هذا الكائن الذكي
ما فيه شي اسمه فطرة ولا غريزة، ولا يحزنون
ولا تأنيب ضمير، ولا ضمير
وإذا شافك تعطي، ما بيفهم أن هذا كمال
لا، خطأ، ليش تعطيه؟
يعني عنده حسبة معيّنة، مدخلة
لا، بس أتوقع الذكاء الاصطناعي
بيفهم من البينات أن الكرم شيء جيد
الله أعلم، ما أدري
تدري وين النقطة الحين اللي ما أستوعبها؟
الحين في ناس يصرّون على شيئين
أن ما فيه وعي عند الذكاء
وأن لا، الإنسان يبرمجه
هاتان ما عادتا كذلك
إذا صحّ الفصل، هذه كارثة
الثانية خطأ، ليش؟
لأن مثلًا خوارزميات قوقل، ضخمة جدًّا
ما يسيطر عليها شخص، يوجد عشرات الأشخاص
كل فريق منهم يسيطرون على نقطة
لكن الكل المجموع
ما فيه أحد يسيطر عليه أصلًا
-وش فكرة الذكاء الاصطناعي؟
-والآلة تعلّم نفسها أصلًا
بالضبط. أنت أصلًا لا تدرك
ما الذي يمكن أن يفعله هذا الرجل
لا يوجد شخص واحد، ولا مجموعة أشخاص
يمكن أن يستوعبوا هذا الكل
هذا أصلًا أضخم منك
صحيح
ما تدري وش يسوي
الشيء الثاني: قديمًا كان الإنسان يمر
وتجيه بيانات
معلومات، يحوّلها إلى علم
أول شي معلومات متفكّكة، يحولها إلى علم
معلومات يحول العلم
ثم يحوّلها إلى معرفة
المعرفة مفهوم أعلى، مترابط
ثم يحوّلها إلى حكمة
حكمة عملية، يعني ينبني عليها
خير، وشر، وأخلاق
وكلما بنى الإنسان معرفته
وعمله على الحكمة
كلما كان أكمل
على كل حال، هذه النتيجة النهائية
الآن الذكاء الاصطناعي، وين يشتغل؟
لن يصل 4 ولا 3 ولا 2
سيظل في 1
في البيانات
حتى موضوع العلم، ما يصل اليه
ولذلك أسميه...
يا جماعة لازم تشوفون هذا الفصل الأخير
اللي اسمه دين البيانات
لهراري نوح
-الحق أنه يتحدث..
-أي كتاب؟
كتاب الإنسان الإله
ليس كتاب الإنسان العاقل، الإنسان الإله
الذي ظهر بعده
«Homo Deus» ؟
إيه، تُرجم بالعربية إلى الإنسان الإله
في هذا الفصل «دين البيانات»
طبعًا أكثر الكتاب
هو بنفس الحجم تقريبًا للـ «الإنسان العاقل»
مقدمة ممتازة عن التقنية والعلم
ممتاز، ممتاز جدًّا
وكيف وصلنا إلى النتيجة
لكن بالأخير تحدّث عن هذا الشئ
اللي سماه دين البيانات
تقريبًا 20% من الكتاب
أفضل من اللي يكتبه الآخرون
لأن الآخرون كتبوا بشكل تقني بحت
ومعلوماتي بحت
هو يتحدث عنه من منظور فلسفي وفكري
وشيءٍ من الأخلاقي
مهم جدًّا جدًّا
صحيح أن فيه شيء من الخيال قد لا يتحقق وكذا
مو مشكلة
بالعكس يوسّع خيالك
ويظل ما أحد يعرف وين احنا رايحين؟
يمكن يكون أبعد مما قال، ممكن يكون أفضل
الله أعلم
جربت تشات جي بي تي؟
جربته إيه. بالعربي جربته
أذهلك؟ وللا..
هو مذهل، الحقيقة مذهل
ولكن ليس بالشيء
الذي يبدو عند اللغات الأخرى، يختلف
وأعتقد أنه هناك نماذج تطوّرت جدًّا جدًّا
في صديق طلب منه يسوي عقد
إيه، يسهّل
بعدين قال له لا، أبي أفضل
راح طلع له أفضل
وقال أبي أفضل
ما عاد أحتاج محامين
أعطي كل واحد منهم 20 أو 30 ألف
بس فيه، لا هنت
أنت قلت أن فيه كتب تنصح بها
في الأخلاق
فلو بس، كرمًا، ترسل أسماءها
ونحطها للناس عشان يستزيدون
في موسوعة الناس لا يعرفونها
لابن تنباك
ابن تنباك هذا الدكتور
شسمه؟
مرزوق
مرزوق بن صنيتان بن تنباك
موسوعة ضخمة
ممتازة، ممتازة
مثلًا كتيب الرجولة
كتيب المروءة
كتيب الكرم
كتيب العقل
كتيب حسن الخلق
يا سلام..
تقريبًا 45 مجلد، صغير جدًّا
فيها الشعر والكلمات والتحليل اللغوي
ممتازة جدًّا، حقيقة
وفيه نضرة النعيم
حقت صالح بن حميد
ممتازة
هذه اللي أنت أحلت عليها
ولكن في نظري، أنها ما فيها أصالة
هي فيها جمع في الحقيقة
اللي هي عنده، تكفيه
ولكن هذه أفضل منها
فيها أصالة، وفيها لمسات خاصة فيه
وفيها عاد أشياء أخرى
تحتاجها
مثلًا كتاب الذريعة
مثلًا مدارج السالكين
مدارج السالكين، اسمه مدارج
ترى خصّص المروءة والفتوة
بدأ بالفتوة قبل المروءة
المفروض العكس
ولكن نظرًا لأنه وضع الأعلى
وجعلهما متقاربتان، يعني جعل الفتوة أعلى
فنكتفي بهذا القدر